...
you
oh hello can you hear me now? is everything okay? good, good, good, hi, hi, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, we hear you, okay, good, good, good, welcome, welcome, welcome
um oh I suddenly got very dizzy um okay I think everything should be good with the audio
let me turn on the background music because it's, it fits our theme
hello oh my god what an eventful day right?
okay well if you saw my twitter it was slightly eventful because I made my announcement
I'm once again eating sausage rolls
Strani asks if you are on RuneScape with her right now, no?
I don't even know how to play RuneScape, I don't have RuneScape
why is someone trolling her?
is someone trolling her as me or something?
I'm dipping my sausage rolls in sriracha sauce too
it was an imposter?
you have RuneScape it came free with your xbox? why do you assume I have an xbox?
I don't have an xbox
don't forget to drink your water if you're gonna read everything ah fuck is there a lot of dialogue?
this is gonna be rough, okay
how long is this game? right yeah sorry today we're playing the coffin of Andy and Lele
I've never played it before, apparently there's some themes that relate to me
um now I know the, I know the um
can I say it? I think I can say it
I know the incest route is like an optional route so you're gonna have to um
you're gonna have to lead me down that route
okay um we're gonna have to go down that route
you and me both are going down the incest route
it's 10 hours long ah shit
um okay well we can't finish it today then
of course we're intentionally doing it, what do you mean?
no blind run? no of course do you wanna, you're gonna watch me play this fucking game
and you're gonna expect me to not go through the incest route, what do you mean?
of course we're going down the incest route, it's not even a choice
I can't do a 10 hour stream, I'm sorry
right before we start let me test something
my name is Andy I don't think I should be watching this
well you're in luck because my name is Lele
today I'm Lele or is it Lele? it's not Lele is it?
it's Lele right?
it should come naturally to me? I don't know
I'm not really good at getting the endings I want in visual novels
so I don't know if I'll be able to get the right ending
alright so I think I fixed the super chat, not the super chat, the tip
so let me test it out
what should I say?
give me a sentence to test the tip alert with
give me a funny sentence
to see because I have text to speech on but I'm not sure if it's gonna work
Pog? come on get creative
just the tip
okay
it means the best little sister in the world she's the only girl I need in my life and I love her a lot
I'm happy I still remember that
are you gay? why are you acting so gay?
just the tip
it worked
thank you Rigo
thank you for the tip
thank you for the tip big brother
okay well this is what I was gonna say
are you gay? why are you acting so gay?
please just put the tip
can you hear it good?
nice tip can you hear it good?
is Jake around? shut up
do I need to send you the therapy?
to fix that little...
sorry I'm not trying to get problematic here
can you hear very well? okay
right glad you're back
I'm glad to be back
Jake is my neighbor that I rant about
yeah shut up about Jake
do you suffer from homosexual psychosis?
right from state fire
how do we send tips? it's in my description the stream elements link
okay
let me show you the game
are you gay? why are you acting so gay?
remember to kiss your sister
oh why is it cut off shit? let me fix that
let me fix that
thank you for the tip
uh uh uh uh uh
I gotta make it wider I guess
okay there now I shouldn't get cut off
what are you eating? I'm eating sausage rolls
from
from the drugstore?
next door I think
yeah I'm eating sausage rolls from the drugstore
like frozen ones
they say being gay isn't a choice but a competition
if that's the case then I'm dk
what's dk mean?
um
display capture
this one there we go
what the fuck
why is this game so strangely formatted?
is that good?
oh my god
why do I have so many formatting issues?
that should be good
there okay
disqualified oh why are you disqualified though
are you gay?
why are you acting so gay?
I'm happy I'm actually Andy
I'm happy you're actually Andy too
thank you for the tip 420
okay okay okay okay
let's play let's play let's play
um so I can't see my mouse
I think that's on purpose right?
we play we don't
oh okay
was the space to interact
exit shift to run
I have to run in this game?
it's an RPG maker game
the native resolution is a square
oh that's stupid they should stop doing that
no one's monitor is square shaped anymore
make them rectangle
like a freaking normal person
weed eater
what do you mean weed eater?
are you accusing me of being on drugs?
this isn't a horror game right?
right?
alright hold on
okay I finished my sausages
um
Lay Lay
I don't
want to
well I do
I don't think I should use that voice ramp
are you gay?
why are you acting so gay?
an eating animation is the absolute best
okay now it shouldn't get cut off
Jesus thank you for the $3 tip
it's not eating animation
it's just my mouth moving
I made Andy a smoker
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
just go over and
are you gay?
why are you acting so gay?
I don't suffer from my psychosis
I have sex with her
are you having sex with the voices in your head?
what?
use the deco voice for Andy?
I can't I can't all the time
I don't know what she's saying there
something to something you
I thought she's your friend
mom said you'd help me with anything
are you gay?
why are you acting so gay?
snacks money for the good girl
thank you for snacks money
thank you Wolfman Dave
thank you
oh psychosis
oh
two words
not psychosis psychosis
what was it? I don't suffer with my psychosis
I have sex with her
we'll get in trouble
are you gay?
why are you acting so gay?
love you little sis
hope you enjoy the game
oh thank you Akari
I hope I enjoyed it too
thank you for the five dollars
okay good morning Ashley
as much as you love feeling sorry for yourself
it's time for a little interlude
or should I actually show you the dialogue
that's probably better huh
something like that so you can actually
see the dialogue
okay
oh it's titled find your entrance
to not die
ready set go
are you gay?
so gay
you don't have to test the tips anymore
it works
thank you for the tip
oh my gosh
come on can you give me more than just the tip
I want more
okay wait I need to
make it a little quieter
like one percent
no
three percent
I don't know
what do I do here
oh is that me?
did you pass your test today?
I don't know yet I didn't get it graded
I'll let you know when I get it back
okay I have to give food to eat right?
right?
is this the food?
junk and unpaid bills they cannot be eaten
are you gay?
why are you acting so gay?
more you say
thank you for the $50
oh I got more than the tip
thank you
it's Lele
yeah oh yeah we have to feed Lele
you're used to filling your stomach with water
that's not true at all
but it's not enough your body needs sustenance
nah nah
I'll be eaten
the coffee machine sits alone inside and abandoned
there are only so many times you can brew the same
grounds so no more
coffee in this house
brew the same grounds
wait I don't know enough about coffee
how's that work?
should we all tell sis this is kind of a horror game?
is it?
can I eat the trash?
this is where you and your older brother pile your trash
it's already been scattered several times
and this is utterly
exhausted as the food source
we're eating from the trash?
it's not a horror game?
it is a horror game and you're telling me it's not
so that I get surprised
what is that?
a can of tomato! amazing
you should show that to your brother
okay
wait what?
I've been locked in
it's not exactly horror?
it has horror elements
okay okay I'll come show you
which way? where's the door?
this way? the bathroom door is locked
oh this is the bathroom
okay you're not in here
where are you?
oh there you are
hi I have a can of tomatoes
tada
oh he looks annoyed
not the reaction you were hoping for
tada
we're not eating that
no
that's the very last thing we have Ashley
why are they so poor?
it's just disturbing
psychological horror
can I like a moray then?
horror
I'm a horror so a horror game is perfect for me
I think we should hold on to it a little longer
quit your complaining
you're energetic enough
to go rummaging through our trash
so clearly you're not dying yet
huh?
how did you know it wasn't?
because I hid it there away from you
I live in a den of snakes
ah don't round me up
you're making me hungry
eat this pussy then
do you know what?
do you know what would help with that?
Andrew my dear?
no but the tomato
I can't fucking read
this is not a good game for me to play
are you poor?
why are you so poor?
they're in quarantine?
no put the tomatoes away somewhere
put them in my mouth I will
I can see that your heart is set on this
fine let's eat them then
screw our future selves
time for you to go cook some tomatoes
why are we living in such a
such a stinkin
warden
every line you read is filled with thirst
is it? hello
if you won't make a sound
I'll assume you're dead
and I don't bring food to the dead
you don't bring it to the living either
I'll take that as a yes still alive
and don't blame me for the delivery guy screwing up
can you go grab something for us?
oh from the store for us?
nah not my job
I'll check in on you later bye
no wait
wait wait come back
he doesn't
your voice is perfect for this?
I don't think it is
I don't really think I sound like her
god damn it
let me out
ok fine
wait can you hear the sound effects good?
yeah that's good
ok we'll fine I'll cook my tomatoes
you boil the canned tomatoes to make delicious boiled canned tomatoes
wow
there's even a little bit of pepper left to season with
this is some gourmet stuff right here
no salt though
well we're white people aren't we so it doesn't really matter
we can handle it
your voice is perfect in general
thank you
you've used all of it to spike your water
in order to avoid over hydrating yourself
while drinking
to fill your stomach
what the fuck
well how is it
at this point you could feed me a can of worms
and I'd say it's the best thing I ever ate
this is so depressing
kiss ass
no I'm saying that's how hungry I am
it is in that moment
an ominous audio assault to your eardrums
are you kidding me
the neighbors at it again
want to take a peek? no
but I'll come along if you do
balcony key
oh he's following me
he's so cute
salt is overrated
no it's not
season your fucking food
guys
it's jake
what's he doing over there
can't really see squat from here
if you should take a leap of faith towards the neighbors
balcony we're gonna die
don't even think about it
oh he's no fun
guess you'll have to set something up to cross
the chair
an ashtray
there are no cigarettes left to smoke but it's still good for bashing things in
like your head
seasoning
good at least you salt pepper onions and garlic
use more than just salt
pepper onions and garlic
use all the seasonings you can
are you kidding me
I might be white but I can appreciate some good seasonings
alright we have to find something to
put right
please hold my hand in this game by the way
I don't really know how to play any games
oh my god let's have sex right now
your parents have fucked
yeah we should too then come on
complete the loop complete the cycle
let's do it
are you alright
these goddamn DIY shelves
I swear
is that it
a wooden plank oh I did it wow I'm such a pro
I'm such a pro
patience I don't like being patient
I'm not patient like that
I want it now
let's go
hey shut up in there
oh demons from hell
here my plea
holy ones I come seeking your advice
what am I doing wrong
I thought that was perfect
can I use my mouse to click no
hold on let me actually put my
keyboard like in my lap so I don't have to
I can sit comfortably
and lay back a little
are you gay
you're acting so gay
thank you to lord satan
thank you for the tip can't you
scared the shit out of me
oh yeah you're right it's my tattoo on the floor
okay I thought that was perfect
I knew I should have killed that guy
when I had the chance
gay jump scare
since you're the hex maniac
you should probably know what he did wrong
oh did he do something wrong
it wasn't paying attention
what do you make of that
everybody needs a hobby I guess
forget this isn't it
isn't it almost time to let us watch tv
what the fuck
what in the communism is going on here
let us watch tv
the remote is dead just push the buttons on the tv
meh
what a pain
fine I'll fetch some batteries for you
I always have to do everything around here
yeah yeah what was you
it is
I have to find batteries
he's trying to summon visucky
he's trying to summon faun lapisem
faun lapisem
let us watch tv
um
where would I find batteries
oh my god is this his room
the trash liar hopes and dreams
exactly where they belong
what
I gotta bring my microphone closer
it's in the alarm clock in the bedroom
oh real
I do that too
I do that all the time
where is the alarm clock
oh there it is
got batteries
got milk
here you go
no I've decided I'll hold on to them
we might need them later
for what exactly
why are you being so difficult about this
I'm not I'm taking on the her
her
herculean
is it herculean
I don't know herculean
task of offering a tv myself
the first one
whatever makes you happy I guess
thanks for tuning in
today we share with you some
joyous developments in regards to the tainted water situation
we're happy to announce
that all apartments to which the tainted water
have been delivered have been secured
it has been three months since the first
incident was discovered
and the death toll is now comfy 53 total
no biggie
the quarantine period
for those whom are at risk
has been extended for another two weeks
again
and to our friends in quarantine
thank you for helping
thank you for keeping your disgusting
parasite infested bodies
far away from me
what oh shit
huh
literal world record
paced through the incest route
I'm not gonna get a world record
for it
plus I don't need to get a world record
I'm already going through that route in real life
sorry it's
thank you for your continued
consideration to the public safety
that's all for today cheers
I'm going to bed
you decide to do the same
oh my I'm dreaming
Ashley wait mom where are you going
mean your father will be staying in a hotel for a bit
I thought
they said we should stay at home until
I didn't drink anything
mom not booze
not dirty contaminated water
nothing the only thing I've drank
is some orange juice from a carton
we love you even if you have parasites
but you have parasites too
what do you mean
I'm gonna miss my bus
you and Andrew can join us later
oh that was a lie
alright this won't hurt a bit
the nurse takes a needle in you
it hurts like a motherfucker
there we go
and now you
how long do we have to stay at home
the results from your blood work
will be done tomorrow
so if everything is well you're free to
come and go as you please after that
personally I'd like you more with parasites
what is that
huh
and if not then you'll get to see
what happens if not
that's all for now take care
stop calling me Ashley please
if you need something ask the workers
there I can't do anything for you
I don't want to hear about these lies
of starving anymore
why the hell would I lie about this
listen this new apartment
is a bit of a fixer-upper so I'm really busy
besides
isn't Andrew there with you
what do you need me to pacify you for
you need to you get to lays around
all day doing nothing
I don't know what you've got to complain about
anyways I've got to go
please don't call me anymore I won't answer
would you love us if we were the parasites
are you talking about like the anime parasite
the parasite could she cut me acting up
what are you guys talking about
you'd still love us even if we have parasites right
of course of course
I'll suck those parasites right out if you don't worry
Ashley bro the parents know something's up
I'm sorry
what the parents are in on it
after reminiscing all night
you wake up as one does
instead of ruminating upon
your misery you decide to clean the house
up a bit
wow this is
this is just like real life
what else can I do
what
oh my god it's just like yesterday
when we did our laundry together
oh did we hit 4k
did we hit 4k subscribers
no way
oh we did thank you for 4k
yay
thank you thank you
yesterday I finished my slime girl ASMR script
so I'm hoping
to upload
upload that soon
4k on each
yeah
thank you
yippee
slime girl
I already saw the sketch
for the thumbnail
because I commissioned
an artist for it
and it's really cute
I'm literally a slime girl
it's super super cute you'll love it
anyways continuing
yeah I hope there's no culling
cause that's gonna fucking suck if I get culled
oh I'm not drawing the sketch
I commissioned an artist
yawn
you're cleaning what a waste of energy
that's not true you're a waste of energy
thanks
just don't overdo it what do you mean overdo it
you can't overdo cleaning
come to think of it do we even have any detergent left
I don't know
are you making me do laundry all alone
oh okay
okay
too exhausted
um
do I need a rag?
are you gay?
why are you acting so gay
you're a slime girl
I'm so fucking jelly
is that supposed to be a joke
thank you disco man sir
when you're starving
any amount of energy spent is a waste
no that's not true
energy talking to me
is never a waste
um
am I supposed to find
what am I supposed to
I wish I could make my chat bigger
maybe I should look on my phone
I'm literally too blind to see chat right now
in front of my screen
hold on let me open chat on my phone
um
okay
there
now I can look at chat easier
ugh
detergent probably in bathroom
oh
okay
wait
okay in the bathroom
was the bathroom here? no that was the bedroom
amy do you need glasses yes
I am wearing my glasses right now
but I'm still really blind
um detergent right here
now what
laundry
what else could you clean
um oh here the mop
and then clean all this shit
over here all this poop
poop pooped on the floor because it wasn't me
was it you
talking to you gives me energy
aww you're so sweet
2.0 should have glasses
I want to design a 2.0 I think on Monday
with you maybe I can add
glasses I don't know I feel like that's not
I feel like that's not cute though
like glasses aren't cute
you know
I shit it a lot oh my god
look at you making me clean up your shit
how disgusting
glasses are cute
I don't know I feel like
I don't know how to make them
look cute with like
cause I want an emo design right
and I feel like glasses don't really
they don't really
um look emo
is that everything
what else can I do
cute and nerdy
oh trash bags get the trash bags
get the trash bags what
Aussie circle shades I don't know what those are
like
as a glasses wear
all my feelings I'm a glasses wear
too okay
I'm shitting on both of us right now
make them oversized in the frame shape like skulls
but if I'm going to add glasses
I want them to be actually like
terrible and not like a silly
a silly toggle you know
what am I supposed to do please hold my hand
the fallen books oh okay
okay
there we go
oh
make the uh oh I already read that
the mess you did in your parents room
that needs to clean it okay okay now what
now what now what
oh my god
you're feeling dizzy
I'm having an aneurysm
I told you not to overdo it
that's kind of cute good news once again
some of you may have heard from your loved ones
that there's been supply shortages
in the quarantined households
are we pleased to announce that all of you
all of that has been taken care of
it has
does it look like I'm eating right now
on that note we'd like to remind all of you
to not enter the contaminated apartments
no your friends don't need anything from you
everything is taken care of
should you still feel the urge to help
the staff will be administrating bullets
directly into your brain as a thank you
I hope that clears things up a bit
moving on to a next story
a brand new art museum will be
you drift back into unconsciousness
this could be us but you're playing
okay hold on
oh okay wait I was gonna get more water
you're too tired to get the phone
hello
of course what is it
the shift in the tone of his voice makes
your ear strain
no no go ahead someone is talking on the other side
okay hold on I'm actually gonna go get more
water
fun fact Andrew will spend a lot of time playing
with Ashley's hair
that's so cute
excuse that
I don't know why that opened
oh my phone's falling
that's why it opened there we go
okay I'm gonna go get water BRB
should I put the BRB screen on
oh
I'm signing off, I'll see ya.
Hello, I'm back.
I didn't go pee, I just went to get more water.
Go through the homework for real on each and ton look folder.
I don't have a homework folder on this computer profile that is.
Maybe on a different computer profile I do, but you're never going to see that one.
You don't know the password to that one.
Right.
Um, Amy, did you wash your hands?
I didn't pee, I just went to get more water.
Shut up.
I didn't, I don't need to wash my hands.
Someone's talking on the other end of the line, but you can't make out the words.
They sound more and more upset as they talk, though.
Well, that's, I mean, I can't do anything about that.
Or I can try talking to her, but sorry if my cadence when reading is shit.
Um, yeah, it is.
No, it's not big bro is cute 2024 and it's not I love on each and 13.
Come on, I'm not, I'm not that predictable.
What the hell?
You think so lowly of me that I would put such a shit password?
Um, no, I'm not angry.
I'm just sounds like he's talking to a girlfriend.
No, I can you let me talk?
What's on the other end must have said no.
It's increasingly allowed, but you still can't make out all the words.
Always about you don't lay and Ashley and have the time to think.
Just can't anymore.
He is talking to his girlfriend.
It's not dick on 69.
Come on.
I'm not that cringed.
If you loved us, you'd make a deliberately easy password.
It is.
It is an easy password.
It's my, um, it's my school password from like when we had computer class in like second
grade.
It's the same password from all the way back then because I still remember it.
I might be stupid, but I still have okay memory.
It is not password 1234 shut up.
So that's it then.
Now it's quite on both ends.
All right, I guess.
What else is there to say?
Sorry.
I should really, I really don't see why I should be held accountable for a faint beep beep beep
of a dropped call can be heard.
Ah.
Sorry.
What was it?
My ex-girlfriend apparently.
Ooh, she dumped you.
Why is that?
Why do you think?
How should I know?
Maybe because you're a person-infested home buddy that's apparently permacore.
Or because she found someone new.
It's been a few months, buddy.
Or maybe she just didn't like talking to you.
Or maybe she just didn't like you that much in the first place.
Whatever you say, Ashley.
It might have been something more tact-ta- tactful to say.
Yeah, he only needs me anyways.
It doesn't matter.
You don't need a freaking girlfriend.
Whatever.
You pretend to sleep until you really fall asleep again.
Now you've been out for a while.
Whatever.
You pretend to sleep until you really fall asleep again.
Now you've been out for who knows how long.
You figure you should check on your brother.
A VHS player cannot be eaten.
I wouldn't try to eat- oh!
Don't jump!
Someone from your apartment is getting hauled into an ambulance.
Hey, me too!
People are yelling from their windows and balconies.
I need some help too.
Please, please.
I'm starving.
Soon the ambulance leaves in a hurry.
Technically anything can be eaten.
If you're brave enough, anything can be eaten, and anything can be a dildo.
If you're brave enough.
Soon the ambulance leaves in a hurry.
Wee!
Telling me surprise, they actually got that person some help.
I figured they'd just let her die.
Maybe she did die.
She wasn't moving.
As if they'd have their sirens blaring for a corpse.
Then what do you suppose was her emergency?
No idea.
Nobody showed up when you fainted.
Well, did you call for anyone?
What do you think, dumbass?
I don't know.
Maybe she went into labor or something.
Yeah, maybe.
I think they'd bring me food if I got pregnant.
No.
Let me finish.
How'd you even get pregnant in here?
Well, we do have that one charming fellow right next door.
Over my dead body.
You're the only one that's supposed to get me pregnant.
He seemed a little off his rocker, so who knows, he might just end you.
Forget this.
Well, excuse the hell out of me for exploring my options here.
That woman didn't look pregnant anyways.
Whatever, it's just a thought, jackass.
You'd like to go after Andrew and tell him it ain't none of his damn business anyways,
but you're just too exhausted.
He was feeling a little jealous, wasn't he?
After sleeping for a few hours, maybe a few days, who knows,
you're fully revitalized and bursting with energy.
Am I?
I don't think I am.
Yeah, if you keep making babies, you'll have infinite food because you can eat the babies.
Oh, you silly lazy bones.
What day is it? How long have you been locked in your apartment now?
Where the hell does Andrew get the energy to make so much noise?
Is he gonna break out?
I'm gonna screw the lock and his attempting to kick the door in.
Or out, depending on your perspective.
How many more times are you gonna try that?
It's clearly borrowed from the other side.
What else am I supposed to do?
If you don't stop banging on the door, I won't bring you any food tonight.
You won't either way, says you.
The delivery will be here in a matter of hours.
But I guess you don't want anything.
Yeah, that's right.
You better stop banging, banging, banging on that door.
Bounce, bounce, bounce it on my wood.
I'm tired from bouncing on my wood all the time.
You have to wait around nine months, though.
You're right, you're right.
It's not really an infinite food glitch, is it?
You guys, what do you mean, ay-yo, what?
Do you guys not watch anything on the internet?
You don't know any memes?
Could you give me some juice?
What do you mean, some juice?
Some eminade, is that what you mean?
The warden doesn't like hearing the pets squeak at night.
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
Oh, thank you for the three dollars, Anonymous, thank you.
Shut up with my two inch wood!
It's bigger than two inch!
Stop it!
It's gonna feel way bigger than two inch when you're bouncing on it.
Cough, cough, cough.
The man's footsteps fade away.
Do you think they'll really get that delivery today?
Like, I didn't even fuck this up for us, did I?
Unlikely.
Oh, I guess we'll see.
And see you did!
But absolutely nothing was delivered.
Si.
Talk about something!
I got nothing. Try.
Yeah, don't give me any ideas for Patreon food content.
So, parasites.
It's been a few months, are you feeling anything?
Hunger?
You'd think something would happen to us by now, but I haven't noticed anything.
The nurse never came back either.
Like, don't you want to monitor us?
Ugh, who cares?
Me, Ashley, I care.
Well, I don't.
Care, nor care that you care.
I can't believe that two people this hot would not sleep together after months of being trapped.
You've been, you've been normie-pilled, apparently.
Because, um...
Wait, no, not normie-pilled.
Their brother and sister get normie-pilled.
Of course they haven't slept together!
They're normies.
They should, though.
Don't worry, we'll make it happen together.
Aside from starving, it's not so bad here.
Come again?
Aside from starving, I like it here.
Well, I don't.
I want to jump off the balcony.
Ooh, I'll race you.
No, seriously, let's go.
Let's not, though.
I appreciate your eagerness to join me.
Are they normies?
I don't know, I just started the game, I just got here.
Are they not normies?
After the first month or so, they wouldn't care anymore, right?
Oh my god.
Your brain has been rotted by porn.
Come on, guys, use your coffin sets!
But it's a bit too romantic, so I'll pass.
Excuse me?
What, you don't see it?
Just imagine hitting the ground together.
Oh, fuck!
And with such force, our bodies would turn into a pile of gory mush,
never to be separated.
Our remains would get so tangled up,
we'd have to bury us together in the same coffin.
Hot!
Might as well.
We've been confined together in this coffin of an apartment
for what feels like an eternity already.
I'm not jumping off the balcony with you.
Get your head checked.
I should get my head checked?
He said the line, what line?
Do you mean how is that hot?
It's hot.
It's hot!
No wonder your girlfriend dumped you.
If those are your plans for romance, oh wait, hold on.
Let me have a- let me get a cough drop.
He said the title?
Oh, coffin of an ab-
The title is the coffin of-
Oh, is the coffin-
Is the coffin the apartment?
Is that the coffin?
Yeah, being forever- forever un-
Yeah, forever inseparable from your loving sister wife.
It is hot.
Oh, that makes sense.
I don't know, I just got here.
Okay, that makes sense.
That makes sense, I think.
Not romance, I said romantic.
They're not the same thing.
Romantic just means something is-
The neighbor starts blasting his favorite ritual music
for all to hear.
Again, I wish he'd just-
Did it work?
You feel like you should check up on that.
Hello, Sheevee, my adorable sister wife, hello.
My mommy wife is here.
Um, okay, let's go check on the neighbor, I guess.
Hultus, my lord, you've come.
And you're a little smaller than I imagined.
I- I love it, it's better than I imagined.
That's all I meant.
That's what she said.
What do you offer, human?
Oh, um, I don't have much to give right now.
But if you help me get out of here,
I can get you anything you wish.
Is that no good?
As you wish, human.
My lord, thank you, thank you.
Parish.
What's bro cooking in there?
I don't know, darkness clouds your vision
and you can't see what's happening.
But time your vision returns, the entity has vanished.
Is he dead?
On the ground lay the lifeless body of the Hultus.
Let's go eat his dead body so that way we can-
that way we can, you know, live a little longer ourselves.
Am I already delirious or did you see that, too?
Not J-
I gotta be quiet when I say his name.
Do we, uh, do you want to check up on him?
Well, at the very least, I want to turn off that CD player.
That's what you're concerned about.
I'm not listening to this for the rest of my life, Andrew.
You make it sound like we're gonna die anyways.
Oh wait, any day now?
Well, aren't we?
Well, I'm not.
That's gotta be something.
This guy has-
There's gotta be something this guy has that we can eat.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking bad at reading.
Ooh, Berkeley-
Berkeley time.
Shut up. Let's get in there.
Let's get in there.
The doorknob taunts you from the other side of the cloud.
Break it. Break it.
Break it.
I need something to break it with.
Oh.
I need something to break it to see if there's any junk we can use to break in.
Use the ashrite.
Oh.
Break it. Break the door.
Door unlocked.
Eat his dead body.
That's a lot of meat, you think to yourself.
What?
A lot, apparently.
Is it still illegal if we didn't kill the guy?
Is what illegal?
Well, you know.
We can't eat him.
Isn't that why you were insinuating?
Nah, I was just making an observation.
But we can't.
If we do eat him, then that's it for us.
There's no way we wouldn't get caught once they finally let us out.
But it's not like we killed the guy.
Yeah, that's gotta be at least 10,000 calories.
It could last us a pretty good-
pretty long amount of time.
Let's eat his meat.
Well, I think they should look past it.
Given that there's nothing else to eat.
Well, the staff here admit that they didn't give us food though.
And before that, you're going to tell them-
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
My old rat, Richard, Spanish is poorly from his cage made to bullying him.
Can I get some sisterly emergency to boost his recovery?
He's poorly?
He's poorly.
Cut the bullies' balls off.
If you have problems with your male rats bullying each other, cut their balls off.
And then you'll be fine.
Okay?
That's my sisterly advice.
And it's true.
It works.
Doctors don't want you to know this one life hack
to stop bullying in rats.
Yeah, it works.
There you go.
I'm not talking from experience
because I've never owned male rats
because I don't like their balls.
And I'm not going to pay
to get every single rat I owned
balls cut off.
So that's why I stick to girls.
Worked on my brother too.
I should try it on you,
see if it works on you
to make you less aggressive.
And before that, you're going to tell them
a demon killed him, really?
That'll fly?
Listen, you're overthinking the hell out of this.
Are we doing this or not?
Andrew, I'm expecting an answer.
Wait, are they actually genuinely, like,
going to kill him?
Let me make that clear.
I'm not a rat.
You don't have to be a rat for me to cut your balls off.
We're not aggressive.
You can be.
You haven't seen my marshmallows, but I have.
Some of you are.
Some of you need your balls cut off.
Yeah.
Alright then, let's find something to butcher him with.
Oh god.
Are we actually doing this right now?
It should be in the kitchen. There's a knife right there, isn't there?
Isn't this a knife?
A cleaver.
The average human corpse
contains around
125,000 calories.
That'll last us a good amount of time.
She doesn't like the marrows it's in over.
I love them. Don't even worry about it.
I love them.
I'm just jorkin'.
So you get the arms, I'll handle the legs.
Wait, we're actually doing it?
Are we actually doing it?
Okay, I'll get the left one.
What the fuck?
Wait, it's just the illusion of choice.
It doesn't matter which arm we cut off first.
We can't carry him out in the open like this.
Just be quiet about it.
No, can you go get plastic bags or something?
I'll take care of the rest in the meanwhile,
but I'm counting on you, Andy.
Don't call me that.
Hand him the cleaver.
I guess we're going to get plastic bags
to put his dead body in.
Yeah, dinner's served!
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
It's our neighbor,
Chaky.
I've been saying his name really loudly,
but he could probably hear me.
Well, I guess he's dead in the game, but yeah.
Where's the bags?
Wait, where's the bags?
They were in the bathroom, right?
Girl dinner!
Girl dinner! Girl dinner!
It's time for girl dinner,
and I guess boy dinner since
Andy's here too.
Here you go.
Oh, you got his legs. Good job.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, my God.
This is so fucked up.
A small problem presents itself.
The plastic bags aren't big enough
to fit the whole torso.
Time to cut his head off, too.
Ahem.
This is actually
my first time cutting up a dead body,
believe it or not, yep.
I don't think we can cut through the spine.
Just fold him over.
I don't think that's going to work.
Watch and learn!
You see? Oh, this is so fucked up.
You see?
If anyone happens to be looking out
their window, it'll be a disaster.
Maybe if I use two bags?
Listen, this isn't going to...
Ta-da!
Good God, no.
Don't make me laugh at this.
I don't have the power to make you do anything, Andrew.
All right, all right, enough.
Gather the limbs up and go.
There should be plenty room
for them in our freezer.
I'll stuff the torso
and head in his freezer for now.
Big brain.
I know such cute sibling bonds.
Oh my God.
What a cute little date for them.
I'll go cook...
I'll go cook us something while you're at it.
Yeah, you'll cook quite the something.
Okay.
First time cutting up a dead body,
so the others were alive.
Yep, the others were alive while I cut them up
and they screamed very loudly.
How do I cook?
Let me cook.
What's that noise? Is he still cutting him up?
Can I turn chewing?
You like the sound of that?
How am I supposed to...
Am I supposed to cook him in his own house?
That's kind of disrespectful, isn't it?
To the dead?
To cut him up
and then cook him in his own house?
Oh, am I supposed to put him in the freezer?
Pass me the candy? You want it?
Open your mouth, I'll give it to you.
Ready?
I'll pass it from my mouth to yours.
Should I put him in the freezer?
Oh, there we go.
Which one do I want to eat?
Okay, here you go.
Make sure you suck on it really well, okay?
Go for the leg?
Left leg.
Okay, leg, leg, leg.
Okay.
All right, time to cook.
What are we going to make?
You fry some meat.
Dinner is ready.
Right, so what are we having here?
Pure deliciousness is what.
Eat up.
You first. Munch, munch.
Huh? What?
Oh, you already... okay.
Eat, Andrew. You will not waste this.
Um, right.
Andrew takes a bite of your cookie.
I don't think he likes it.
He begins retching.
Oh my god, she's just like me.
She can't cook.
No kiss to pass it?
I already passed it to you.
Maybe if I eat another one, I'll give you a kiss to pass it on.
Thigh is the best part?
That's true. But this is a man.
I like girls thighs more.
Yeah, do what your sister says.
Man, these fucking pictures.
Oh my god.
Swallow.
All of it.
Gold.
Why is there so much sexual tension right now?
Mm-mm, delicious.
Not the first time she said that to him.
Well, how is it?
It's...
God, I hate picky eaters.
Aw, fuck, I'm a picky eater.
I made this with love.
So you're not leaving the table before you lick the plate clean.
Quit your nagging woman.
Or just like a couple.
Then quit your gagging, you big baby.
Now call him a good boy?
Good boy.
I'll eat it, alright? Just give me a minute.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, eat it.
Under your watchful eye, he slowly finishes his plate.
Good boy, I am so proud.
Just fuck off, Ashley.
What an odd way to say thank you.
Yeah, yeah, thanks a bunch.
I'll clear the table, so leave me alone.
God, he's so emo.
We've got a very limited set of spaces left.
So what do you think I should try next?
Like, I don't know, maybe coriander?
Oh my God, I have such a funny story for that!
Okay, wait, actually pause. I want to tell you a funny story.
Let me tell you this story.
Okay, no, I want to be up close.
I want to be up close and personal for this.
Let me make my model go in front of chat.
Okay, so when I was in high school,
I went to a sleepover with my friends.
And we did that one.
My friend had one of those microphones
with the headphones plugged into them,
and it's supposed to be that challenge
where you're supposed to say a paragraph,
and you can hear yourself talking, but it's delayed.
So the challenge is like, you know,
boop, you booping me?
What are you booping me for?
But the challenge is basically talk clearly, and that's it.
You just, whenever you hear the other person talk with it,
it's just funny, that's all.
Boop my snoop.
Boop me.
I'm ready for the boop.
Okay, um, anyways.
So we were taking turns to, you know,
do the challenge of like speaking clearly with a delayed,
what's it called, a delayed audio of our voices.
I know I'm explaining it badly,
but basically when it was my turn,
I decided to do a copy pasta.
I decided to say a copy pasta.
And the copy pasta was the one of the guy
who was pretending to sell weed to his school,
like to his classmates at school,
but in reality he was just selling them oregano.
And I had never seen the word oregano before.
So when it was my turn to read my copy pasta,
I said oregano the entire time,
and I just pronounced it oregano.
The whole time they didn't know I was selling them oregano.
Oh sorry, I turned off the desktop audio
so you could hear me talk.
Thank you for the tip discomancer.
Oregano.
And now I still have the video of me,
of me, because they recorded me
and I still have the video of me just saying
and I was selling them,
I was packaging oregano
and selling it to my classmates.
Do you want me to post a copy pasta for you to read?
Surely it won't be something bad.
If it's not something bad, go ahead.
How do you say munic?
Munich?
I don't know.
That's the British...
Wait, oregano is actually pronounced oregano
in British terms?
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
Oregano.
Yeah, I know it's oregano.
But now I sometimes just say oregano
to make people mad because I think it's funny.
She says it like,
how are you supposed to say it?
Leak the audio.
Yeah, no.
No.
Anyways, coriander?
Alright, I'll try some of that tomorrow.
I'm off to bed now, goodnight.
Night night.
Okay.
Where's the bedroom?
What is that sound alert?
It's just my sound alert.
What do you mean?
It's my sound alert.
How do I sleep?
Is this not my...
Oh, these are the parents' bedroom.
Oh, sorry, that's the parents' bedroom.
You were correct, just British.
Wow, that's crazy.
I was British all along
and I didn't even know it.
Said she likes you.
Who?
My friend from school.
Or at least I thought she was a friend.
So are you gonna...
Are you gonna be her boyfriend?
Gross?
No.
I should teach her a lesson.
Oh my god.
You're my brother, mine.
I'll make her think twice
before stealing from another woman.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, you're a girl too.
What's that supposed to mean?
Somehow you don't count as a lady in my mind.
Or as a person for that matter.
Screw you.
I am the most personous lady in the world.
So anyways,
I'm gonna take her to that old warehouse
and lock her in one of the crates.
Yeah, yeah.
Seriously.
Mom gave me some money
to go buy groceries.
Are you coming with?
Focus, Andy.
Let's leave her sitting there all night.
That'll show her.
Let's not.
You should go ask her to hang out.
She won't say no then.
Lately, I don't want to.
Just go over and ask her to come with you.
I feel like you almost said this exactly.
I've never said that before.
But I'm saying it now.
Take her to the warehouse
and we'll see what happens.
Come on.
Mom said you'd help me with anything.
I thought she's your friend.
Well, I thought so too.
And she can be my friend again afterwards.
She just needs a reminder
of how to do it properly.
Well, get in trouble.
I'll only let her out
when she promises not to tell on us.
She's been getting tips from Mercy.
I'll let you in on a little secret,
but I don't need tips from Mercy.
It's all coming from me.
Sai.
Do it, Andy.
I guess.
Hooray! You're the best!
Today's episode is titled
Andy and Lately and the Bitch in a Box.
One day, you'll be in a bitch in a box
and your friends will take turns
pissing on the ground above.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
What do I do about these hussies around you?
Where do you learn these words?
The bitch is you.
I'll take you out to play
and then when I'm done,
it's back into the box with you.
I really ought to kick your ass
one of these days.
Huh?
Yeah, who do you think taught Mercy?
What?
What is taking him?
He wouldn't have forgotten our plans, would he?
Grr.
Is he coming?
Finally!
Huh?
What are you doing here?
Surprise!
I want to hang out too.
Oh.
I mean, I guess that's fine.
Say, did you tell your mommy you're here?
No, why?
Just wondering.
I mean, I'm surprised she let you come
hang out with a boy.
No way, she thinks I went to study with Julia.
But why are you here, Ashley?
Divine intervention.
What's that even mean?
It means she's full of crap, don't listen.
So, are we going inside or what?
Is that allowed?
These flags be crimson?
Ignore them.
Just put on some rose-tinted glasses, okay?
They're not real.
You're being a little crazy right now.
I love it.
Let's find a way in right now.
Where are we going in a box?
Box?
Get in the box?
Get in the box, bitch.
Get in the box.
Wait, I'm confused.
Oh, shit.
Are we actually going to nail her into a box?
The drop off on the other side of the window is too high.
Though I wouldn't mind convincing Blanc-
Blanc- Blanc.
Let me take another cough drop.
Yeah, luckily you're colorblind.
Did you know it's more common for dudes to be colorblind?
Isn't that so lucky for me?
We're just Lillie, Leigh, Ann, and Amy Beacons.
We are one.
There is no ending in beginning to us because we are one and the same.
I wouldn't mind convincing Blanc to jump anyways.
To maybe twist her ankle.
Maybe break her neck.
Is something wrong?
Nah, but we can't go in this way.
Why did they nail this metal sheet thing on the wall?
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
They're not red flags.
They're fun facts.
They're just fun facts.
50 fun facts you didn't know about, Amy,
but you're about to learn right now in this stream.
What's Ouroboros?
Is that, that sounds familiar.
Ouroboros?
Looks like there's a hole behind it.
Perfect.
Tear it open.
What?
I can't do that.
It's okay.
I won't tell anyone.
As in, I literally can't do it dumbass.
Not without some tools at least.
Huh.
Even though it's this flimsy?
Yes.
Bro, what a weak little bitch boy.
I like smart guys over beefy ones.
Shut up, bitch!
That's my man!
Who asked?
Wait, so we need more tools?
What about this thing?
A steel mallet.
I can't really think of a way a mallet
would be useful to us in this situation.
I sure can.
Ouroborialis?
Is that what Ouroboros means?
Oh, snake eating its own tail.
That's what it means?
Mmm.
Mmm, mmm.
Yes, yes.
Yes, the Ouroboros of Emi and Lele.
Yeah, that's what we are.
Does it help us get in the warehouse?
Oh my god.
Wait, I have to fart.
Hold on, hold on, I have to fart.
Fuck.
God damn it.
It's not coming out.
My butthole got shy.
Damn it.
I literally stood up from my chair
and turned around so I could face them like
and then I didn't want to come out.
God damn it.
I'm sorry, boys.
Next time, we'll get them next time.
Right in my face, do it.
I tried, I wouldn't come out.
I can't even, I can't even do it.
I can't even do it.
It got shy, I'm sorry.
Okay, let's continue.
Okay.
Why is my chat frozen on my phone?
Am I going to be the first farter?
I was not, I was not the first farter.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, Lay Lay, I don't even want to know
what you had in mind.
What are you guys talking about?
It's nothing.
Let's keep looking.
The thing.
You use the back of the hammer to pull out the nails.
Cough, wow, it sure is cough cough kind of dusty in here.
First a fart first to win, what are we winning?
There needs to be a prize.
You gotta, you gotta kind of, you know.
I can't think of the word.
I'm trying to think of the word I want.
A kiss is a prize?
Okay, okay, I can compete for a kiss.
The sharp ender.
Makes me wonder about my, oh, makes me worry about my asthma.
It's fine, it's fine.
Oh, I know, how about some hide and seek?
Ugh, you're such a kid.
Huh?
Annie wants to play too.
You do?
What?
Oh yeah, sure.
See?
Well, I mean, it's fun every once in a while.
Oh my god, I hate her.
You totally want to, you totally wanted to play too, you child.
Albeit, I'm gonna count to ten.
Hundred, count to a hundred at least.
Okay.
One, two, alright, let's find a good box to shove in.
Don't tell her where that kiss is gonna be.
What?
You wouldn't kiss anywhere weird, right?
It's gonna be on the mouth, of course.
Okay.
You still want to do that?
Of course.
She said no one knows she's here.
It's perfect.
Lele, you promised.
Now hurry up, before she's done counting.
Where is she?
Where's the box?
How do I shove her in the box?
Put her in the box.
This container's already full.
There's no empty boxes.
Where do I put her?
Ah.
Oh, now this'll do.
There isn't any lock on it, though.
Well, we don't have it.
We don't actually have...
Ah!
Well, we don't actually want to lock her in.
You get forehead kisses at best?
Why?
Dummy kisses work too.
Yeah, on the lips.
I won't accept anything less than on the lips.
We don't have...
We don't...
Fuck, I can't fucking read.
We don't actually want to lock her in.
The hell we don't...
Place a stick or something between the rings.
That'll keep it closed.
Won't the stick just break?
No, well, if she's hunched inside,
I doubt she'd have leverage to...
Ready or not, here I come!
Oh, crap, she counts too fast.
It wasn't that fast, really.
Ahaha, let's hide.
Okay.
Wait, where do I hide?
Where do I hide?
In the box, right?
Fuck.
Where do I hide?
Here?
Tell me where to hide!
Ah!
Oh wait, I thought I saw her walk in.
Where do I hide?
Top right.
Here?
Where do we get a stick anyways?
Andy picks up whatever wooden debris is at his feet.
I guess this'll do.
Well...
What do you think?
Is she pretty?
A stick?
No, who do you think, dumbass?
Ah, she's fine, I guess.
He's supposed to say no.
Found you!
Both of you.
Who hides in the same spot, idiots?
SHUT UP, BITCH!
It was my spot first.
Then you're it.
Far through the crack in the box?
Yeah, I'm prettier.
Yes, yes, I'll go count.
Andy goes to count outside.
My hiding spots are the best.
I know a really good one.
Come take a look!
Um, okay.
Let's shove her in this fuckin' box.
Go hide in there.
I think you'll fit in here?
Seems like a bad idea.
It's coming, it's coming!
It was a silent fart, damn it.
Okay.
Seems like a bad idea.
Have so!
I'm gonna get my clothes dirty.
My mom does...
Oh wait, what?
I didn't see the previous message.
She'll get mad if I...
HUNDRED!
Oh shoot, he's coming, hurry, hurry!
I'm getting a phone call right now.
Decline.
Leave me alone.
Let me sniff.
There is nothing to sniff.
It doesn't even smell.
I don't smell anything.
First confirmed fart on stream?
If you believe me, yeah.
Shut up about vibrations!
It's not the kind of vibrations you think it is!
It was my phone!
No, I'm not gonna answer it.
It said it was a survey.
Er, uh, okay.
Hey silly, your friend hops inside the crate.
Yup!
Huh? What was that?
I got you now!
Blank is too weak to throw you off the lid.
Cough, this isn't funny, Ashley.
She's gonna suffocate, isn't she?
Hello, Amy, hello.
She's gonna suffocate.
That magic wand of yours?
I haven't used that yet.
I will update you when I do use it though.
I will.
But no, it was just my phone.
Get your mind out of the gutter.
There you are, Andy, you slowpoke.
Hurry up, she's putting up a fight.
Cough, I can't breathe!
She's actually gonna suffocate!
She alright?
Cough, Cough, please, I-
Shut up already, you drama queen.
Let her out, Lele.
She's just pretending.
No one's ever died from some dust.
Just let her out.
What? You believe her over me?
It's not really about whether I believe her or not.
Fine, you let her out then.
Who cares about me anyways?
Cough, Cough.
Everyone likes her better,
but you like her better too.
But everyone does.
I already know.
Cough, Cough, Cough.
That's fiction, that's fiction.
That's f-
A-
X-
Asphyxiation, siblings, confinement, betrayal.
Nice tags.
I bet you-
I bet you'd rather have a girlfriend
than spend time with me, of course you would.
Oh, come on, I already told you I don't want.
And,
bet,
sniff,
I should say it.
I should voice act for hairlines, at least.
And I bet,
but you only want to hang out with me
because mom told you to.
Well, that's-
I mean, maybe she did, but-
It's not fair.
Cough, Cough, Cough.
Why does everyone like her better?
I'm loud and weird and annoying,
no one likes me at all.
I like you better, Lele.
Prove it,
liar.
Sigh.
I knew it.
Maybe you'd have more friends if you weren't always so-
Not even my own brother picks me over her!
I knew it already.
Did I not just say,
la, la, la,
talk sure is cheap.
God damn it.
Cough, Cough.
Crazy ass castling.
I mean, she's good at it,
she's good at what she does.
Cough, Cough.
Ash.
There.
Are you happy now?
Cough, Cough.
Yes.
Just until morning, okay?
Yes, yes, you're the best.
I like you the best, Andy.
You hear that, Blank?
You get to stay there until morning.
No, please.
Cough, Cough.
Ashley.
Yeah, that girl's gonna fucking die.
I mean, she kind of deserves it,
she was annoying.
Ashley, wait, don't-
Cough, Cough.
Go.
Ashley, please.
Ashley!
Ashley?
Will you wait?
I am now.
If you see my tongue sticking out,
it's because I'm kind of sticking out my tongue.
Cough, Cough.
Maybe she shouldn't have tried to seduce her big brother.
Well, maybe that bitch shouldn't have been such a bitch,
and then she wouldn't die.
Um, okay.
What is it?
Nothing, it's just-
God, what the fuck did we do?
You still on about dinner?
Fine, just starve then.
More for me.
How are you like this?
How are you-
Are you out of your mind?
Listen, I didn't kill the guy,
so I didn't do anything wrong.
You mutil-
You mutilated and ate a corpse, too!
What else were we supposed to do?
Call the warden and let him know he died?
Ashley is giving more of a sociopath than a psychopath?
She's a- what's it called?
S-
She's a psychosis.
That's what she's-
That's what she is.
Uh, yes.
Um, sir, we-
He summoned a demon and then died.
I swear we didn't do it.
Yeah.
I-
We wouldn't have had to admit we were there.
We couldn't-
We could've just told him to go check on that guy.
Andrew, what the hell?
What?
What the hell?
Didn't we both agree on this?
I could've sworn it was your suggestion in the first place.
She's so good at cast lighting!
Yeah, what a girl, boss.
I was hungry-
I was too hungry to think straight, okay?
Now that's some bullshit.
Fine, let's assume it was so.
What-
What do you want me to do about it?
I-
Woosh woosh, there goes my magic wand.
There.
I've absolved you of your sins.
You never took a bite now.
You're welcome.
Oh gee, thanks.
We'll see how-
We'll see how that holds in.
I'm sorry that I'm so dyslexic today.
I don't actually have dyslexia, surprisingly.
We'll see how that holds in the face of the law.
Listen, who cares?
Ugh!
Isn't this, like, some extreme circumstances stuff?
Like, can we be excused?
It's the water company's fault.
First they lock us in for months, and then we don't-
And then they won't even feed us.
And does Kevin fever a real thing?
Maybe we can plead insanity.
I don't know, Ashley.
Sounded out?
Thank you for being so patient.
She's an empath.
They're there.
You know what?
I couldn't get his head off.
Huh?
Like, he didn't fit in the freezer properly.
So I needed to chop his head off, but I couldn't cut it.
His spine was too-
Anyway, I kind of just-
Uh, like, kept cutting around and then pulled it off.
Like some plant.
I don't know.
I just keep thinking about it.
Ugh, I can't fucking sleep, Ashley.
It's-
Come here.
This is a little-
Oh my, they're sleeping in the same bed together?
Aw, thank you for all the encouragement.
I don't know what's wrong with you.
How are you so unbothered?
Moisturized, showered, um, cleansed, unbothered.
Sitting on my couch.
Reading incest.
I don't know, I compartmentalize.
Kind of like we compartmentalize that guy into different freezers.
Ashley!
Andrew, what is it, Andrew?
Oh my god!
Andrew!
Andrew.
Andy.
I-
I told you to stop calling me that.
We're not kids anymore.
Then why are you crying like such a baby?
Now kiss.
She's a woman, Andy. Consequences are ununtered.
I'm not crying.
Mommy, the big bad me did the evil thing.
You shut your own mouth.
Make me a little-
I was gonna say make me without actually reading it.
Make me a little bitch.
Forget this.
Why are they sort of goals though?
I know!
Hey Andy, remember when we used to go on adventures?
What?
Andy and Lay Lay's quest for something or another.
Something or another, remember?
Yeah, they have a second bed and they don't use it.
You're already in character.
I'm basically covering up her entire side, so, you know.
Just pretend I'm her.
Isn't this just another one of those?
I don't know.
Can you just play along for now?
Until we're out of this crappy situation, then we can unpack it all later?
Yeah, we'll go to therapy after this, don't worry.
Or not.
I don't think I will personally, but you can go to therapy.
Like, I could tell a therapist what I've been up to-
Oh, like I could tell a therapist what I've been up to.
Alright, just a thought.
Let's get out of here.
Oh, let's just get out of here.
He literally has screaming night terrors, does he?
Um, like we should have done months ago.
Now that we've got food, don't you want to keep waiting until they let us out?
Hell no, I don't.
They'll throw us in jail right after.
And I don't know which is worse.
Withering in this coffin of a house or getting railed in a prison?
Don't worry, Andy.
I'll be the one railing you in prison.
I see.
You want to escape not only this quarantine, but the consequences of her actions as well.
Preferably, yeah.
This episode is titled Andy and Laylee and the Escape from the Coffin.
Yeah, whatever.
I'm going to sleep now.
Promise.
I promise I'll be the one railing you in jail.
Bend over.
Drop the soap, okay?
Now with my two inch.
More than a two inch.
I'll try again.
I love you, Andy.
Shut that Andy junk up your ass already.
My God.
I don't love you that much.
You make me want to kill myself?
Too bad dividing.
Oh, too bad diving down the balcony is just too romantic for you.
A pillow hits you in the face so hard you see stars.
Two stars.
Your body has absorbed some delicious nutrients and you're feeling mighty better today.
Andy, where are you?
Dividing.
Shut up.
I'm bad at reading.
Where is this dude?
He's gone.
Is he on the balcony?
Wait, what?
What do you think of their relationship so far?
Goals.
Adorable.
Of course.
The freezer is full of delicious meat.
Yum, yum, yum.
Oh, is he in the neighbors?
Oh, okay.
Hello.
Hey there.
Good morning.
Whatcha up to?
I'm looking at this demon summoning instruction manual book thing.
Brave, given things turned out so well for that cultist guy.
It's okay, I can do it.
I'll help you.
Debatable.
I mean, he was successful up to the point he lacked an offering.
Oh.
Anyways, it says here that demons don't think much of humans.
Well, that's good.
We'll have something in common then.
Yeah, yeah.
So they're only willing to do business as long as it's quick and easy for them.
I take it.
Wait, actually, hold on.
I should say, I don't.
I actually want to do a witchcraft.
I actually want to do a witchcraft stream and I want to make potion bottles for you guys
and I want to send them to you, but I don't know if I'll be allowed to.
I think I have to ask, but I really want to do a witchcraft stream where I make little,
like little, not potion, little spell bottles for you.
I think that would be so cute.
And you can tell me what you want me to put in it and I'll put what you want.
And maybe I can even put, I can even write a little handwritten message in there.
That would be so cute and I want to send it to you, but I don't know.
I'll have to ask, I'll have to ask if I can send it to you.
I'm not putting my eminate in it.
It will be completely sane items, okay?
There's not going to be any spit in the bottles.
There's not going to be any piss in the bottles.
There's not going to be any shit in the bottles.
You don't have to buy it.
I'll probably like, I don't know.
I don't want to put it behind a paywall.
Maybe I'll make like a, some kind of pool, choose someone random, you know?
There won't be bathwater, no.
Maybe accidentally sending demons to people's homes.
It won't, it won't be demons.
It won't be demons.
No, there won't be any hair in there either.
I'm not putting any of my personal parts in, in those, in those bottles.
Well, I wouldn't want to get out of here the same way the cultists did,
but I do think this is our best bet for now.
So what will we ask from it?
I don't know.
Okay, then what will we bargain with?
I don't know that either.
Nice.
I just barely woke up.
Give me a minute.
It says here demons prefer human soul, so obviously it's just got to be that.
Where do you get a soul while stuck in here?
What are you looking at?
Nothing.
Actually, what?
I wouldn't thought about it, I see.
Let me keep my thoughts to myself.
Didn't we already share enough?
On second thought, let's not do this.
Oh, come on, I'm not going to sacrifice you.
We'll figure something out.
Let's just set this ritual up for now.
Nine out of ten?
Thank you, Sheebie.
Will you burp into the bottle?
Okay, fine, fine.
If you want me to burp into the bottle, I'll burp into it.
The Gamer Girl bathwater was canceled.
Not because it was horrible, but because it was a biohazard.
Bill almost got fired for that.
Okay, but did we really expect it to be Gamer Girl bathwater?
It's obviously just like perfumed water.
It's not actual bathwater.
Also, if you hear creaking, it's my chair.
I'm not farting.
Okay?
I'm not done reading this yet,
but you can start by replacing the candles for now.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
What?
Replacing the candles.
Put them up.
Replace them.
Okay.
No, I'm not sending lemonade in a bottle.
Oh my God.
Shut up.
I'd obviously make you pay for lemonade.
That wouldn't be free.
Okay, there you go.
I set up the candles.
Done with now.
Now we...
Still alive and kicking, are you?
Uh-oh.
You've been quiet lately, pal.
I'm getting a little worried here.
Si.
Yeah, hi, hello.
One of my guys isn't answering.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, fuck, oh, fuck.
The weirdo one.
You think he croaked me?
But he's just a type B anyways.
What?
How much?
Oh, you.
Type B, what does that mean?
Fine.
I'll check it after my round.
Is that all we would have had to do to get the door open?
Just shut up for two days?
Shit, he's gonna come in and see all this?
No, no, no, no, no, enough.
Go stall him at our door.
I'll clean this up.
He's still gonna find the guy missing unless he checks the freezer,
which is where all this blood is pointing at.
No.
Go before he notices we're not home and keep him until I've mopped up all the blood.
Why, why are you guys blood type B type B blood type B?
Are they like collecting these people for their blood or something?
What do you mean type B?
There should be a corpse below then.
You, you get to be that...
I fucking can't read.
You get to be that corpse if you don't get going already.
I have to clean up the blood.
Clean it up, clean it up.
Oh fuck, get them up.
Okay, get them up, get them up.
You'll see.
What's your blood type?
That's a really good question actually.
I don't know.
Every time I've ever gone to donate blood,
that's not where the mop is.
I used, I went a couple times to donate blood and they said that they would send me a card,
like a donor card that would say my blood type on it,
but they never ended up doing that.
So I don't know if they just never use my blood,
but I actually don't know my blood type.
Mine is O plus.
That's cool.
Ashley, the warden is coming.
What do I do?
Get out, get out of here.
What are you doing here?
Oh shoot.
Silly, the warden soon calls over his buddy.
You get taken back to your apartment after which you and your brother,
you and your brother's wicked deeds are soon discovered.
You donate blood, good girl.
I only did it like twice or three times maybe,
but it worries me that they never gave me a donor card because I even asked.
I said, Hey, why didn't I get a card?
And they were like, Oh, we'll send you one Dory.
So now it makes me feel like I have some sort of disease and they never use my blood because of that.
Because you know, they test the blood that they,
they test the blood that they collect from you.
So I'm now I'm scared I have some sort of fucking disease and they never just,
they just never told me.
And that's why I didn't get a card because they never use my blood.
Andrew, start pole dancing.
Distract the guards.
Guess what?
It went so badly for you that I'm going to let you try again.
No.
Wait, what did I do wrong?
Is that supposed to happen?
But I didn't do anything.
Oh, I have to hide in the closet?
I don't know.
I just got here.
Okay.
I'll hide in the closet.
Readings and salutations.
Anybody home?
I'll create another suicide.
What the?
How did you get in here?
Oh, my savior.
Thank you, Andy.
Sai.
Oh fuck, that's kind of hot.
Andrew doesn't seem to please with you right now.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
You wonder if it's a good time to tell him that this is your fault.
Oh, my God, the bloody hand.
Come on then, Laili.
Let's go.
Shish, I thought I got caught there.
You did.
Happens to the best of...
Right, he do be kind of hot.
Oh, my God.
What do we do now?
Let's escape.
Well, you've done it now, Andy.
You've actually killed a man.
Like, directly.
Yup.
I was a little surprised there.
So where's your mental breakdown?
I'm saving it for later.
Lay off.
I'm reading deleted messages that mods deleted.
You guys are so funny.
I know, I'm sorry, I know.
These standards are impossible.
I know it's, I know it's not, I know.
I can't expect any of you to be murderers.
Actually, I'm not in the mood right now for your shit.
All right.
Oh, looky here.
Got a key to room 405.
405.
What's in here?
Ew, okay.
Women only want one thing and it's a fucking murder.
While loading the jacket pockets, you find a wallet with $600.
Now you got real moral dilemma here, stealing a dead man's wallet.
Oh.
Which one will make him want to fuck me?
I'm guessing splitting it, right?
Right?
A tiny consequence.
He saved your life, you brat.
At least give him some of the cash.
Okay, okay, okay.
Aren't you a sweetheart?
Don't say that, don't say that.
I'll use some of mine to treat you something to some...
I'll use some of mine to treat you something someday.
Maybe?
Okay.
Where do we go?
Do we go to the other room?
You just kept it different now?
What do I do?
It was a 333 split.
But...
You will find two more of them in the game.
Get on you for sharing?
Of course I always share with my brother.
I always...
I will always share everything.
I'm just looking for things to interact with.
Because I don't know what else to do.
You can leave from the neighbor's house.
Yes, I have done that.
Hey, sit down on the toilet.
Actually, no, I'll sit down and you pee between my legs, okay?
Oh my gosh!
That actually worked!
Maybe I'll take a shower.
Not right now, you won't.
Okay, fine, jeez.
No, like leave the apartments.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
You unlocked the door and...
Don't stand behind me like that, jeez.
I just want to make sure we're on the same page about something.
Whatever excuse we had for eating that other guy just went out the window because of your screw up.
Oh, I'm sorry, did I ask you to kill him?
What do you think is going to happen if I hadn't?
Look, I'm not saying I'm not grateful, Andrew.
I am, but what's your point?
I wish he grabbed me like that!
My point is that no matter what happens beyond the store,
you won't speak a word of what went down here to anyone.
Yeah, obviously, obviously.
And it'll no doubt be obvious we did something once this guy's shift ends
and the next warning comes around, comes looking around.
As best we disappear while we can.
Yeah, as you might have noticed, I'm trying!
You see, I'm not sure you're grasping the gravity of our situation here.
Knowing you, you think you're going to find mom and dad.
But I'm saying all of that is off the table.
I didn't plan on anything, actually.
God, that's even worse!
Okay, so you want me to never contact anyone I know ever again?
Because you think they'll snitch on us to the authorities, is that it?
Yes, exactly!
Yeah, fine, whatever.
Capitan, that's what it reminded me of, yeah?
If you're going to be this flippant about this,
it isn't the authorities you need to worry about.
What's that supposed to mean?
Are you threatening me right now?
Ah!
I'm not going to jail just because you think of yourself as impurevious to consequences.
So you're going to take this to your grave and if...
The tear just ran down my leg.
Even if I have to put you in there myself.
Oh my god, please put me in my grave, please!
You don't scare me, Andrew.
Ah!
Don't give me re-
Andi, it smells in hell the damn afraid of you.
Now back the fuck off!
Who do you think you're talking to?
I'm stressed out, Lele.
Truly the ideal relationship.
Okay, yeah, I can see that.
I need to know what you're...
I need to know you're taking this seriously.
There's half a dead guy in our freezer with my fingerprints all over it.
Trust me, I'm in no hurry to tell the world about this.
Hmm? All good? Can we go now?
Yeah, I guess.
Okay, finally.
Though, Andi,
I don't give a rat's ass about mom and or dad or any of my so-called friends anymore.
Not one of them felt it necessary to even answer my calls.
I know my dreams have come true.
They got such a beautifully toxic relationship.
I'm sorry, I still have...
I'm like constantly stuck in on cough drops right now.
Yeah, truly a romantic relationship.
Or come fling food up toward balcony.
Would be quite the feat to throw something so high.
The point is no one even came to try.
So my affections officially died with all the brain cells I lost while starving.
But it's alright because Andi is here with me,
even though he feels like threatening me for some reason.
Sorry.
I guess I lost some brain cells too.
I can tell!
Can't lose what we...
Oh, can't lose what you don't have!
Hahahaha.
Kiss it to our mouth like you said earlier.
There you go.
I don't know if you heard anything.
Oh, fuck you.
I like how they do a little shing.
Alright, alright, let's get the hell out of here, ready?
Oh, what is this?
That's a door.
401 is open!
Oh, fuck off.
Is this our door?
This is all it took to keep us in a wooden board.
It's okay, Andi, I don't have much muscle either.
Your eyes say you're trying to cover me,
but your words do the opposite.
Whatever.
What's the slip of paper say?
They are collecting our blood.
You're welcome, you're welcome.
I wish I was that cough drop.
What's that supposed to mean?
Don't know, don't care.
Yeah, let's just focus on getting out of here.
Okay.
I guess we go in here.
So is this the girl that died?
Hmm.
I sincerely don't care.
Let's just get out of here, please.
Shut up!
I'm working on it, goddammit.
Oh my god, you're so fucking whiny.
Like, I'm trying it, I'm trying it.
We should finish the noodles though.
No, on the fridge.
Notice from now on, AB types won't be given supplies,
except if something's important.
Oh!
We were AB.
Note 403 has an XO for it?
And no, the lady from 302 being hot doesn't count as important.
Stop asking!
Wait, what?
AB can receive from everyone, but only give to AB.
Is the lady from 302 single?
Is your brother single?
Is the toilet, there's nothing of interest inside?
Well, you don't know that, let me check.
Oh, there's notes on all of them.
2A1B.
1O, this crossed over.
Hmm.
Why are you telling me these facts about blood types?
Am I supposed to know?
Should I know this?
Let me out!
What do I do now?
Go in here?
Just want to know?
Stop calling me Imi.
There's no Imi, just Imi.
Who's this girl Imi?
Why do you keep bringing her up?
Jesus.
Stop mentioning her.
What?
Lots of 666's going on.
Imi is my sister?
You have another sister?
Huh?
And you never told me?
What the hell?
Check the warden one last time?
Okay, sorry.
I'll go check on it.
Oh wait, I should be able to leave from here, right?
Because I unblocked it?
This is the warden's place, right?
Oh, the pewter!
They've got a little surveillance camera.
Oh crap, are we on it?
No, looks like it's recording the second floor.
Let me see.
Wait, there's another warden there.
Is that a gun holster?
Didn't the other warden have one?
What's this guy?
You're the far cuter sister?
It better be.
You only had a key to the closest room in a walkie-talkie.
Sorry.
Okay, I know you keep hearing vibrating, please.
It's my phone.
There, I muted my phone so you won't hear any more vibrating.
Ugh.
It is my phone.
They probably work in pairs.
It's not like they have to do anything else
then keep curious people away
and pretend to feed us, I guess.
Well, even then, how are we getting around him?
It's okay, have your fun, I don't mind.
You will know when I have my fun, okay?
I'll make it very obvious.
Oh, there's a key here!
Oh, let's go to the fourth floor.
Oh, can we?
Oh, the third floor, sorry, the third floor.
One A, but it's crossed over.
I'm guessing the crossed over ones mean they're dead.
Oh, hello!
Hey, hey, hold up, don't you dare come any closer.
Who are you?
Your neighbors from upstairs?
What are you doing here?
Get out.
Well, we found the keys and thought you might want to get out of here.
You thought wrong, get lost, huh?
What, don't you understand?
You don't want to get out of here?
That's what I said, why would I want out?
I get free food and can't even play games all day long.
Huh?
Your special phone that has no screen and just one button.
Oh, is this the hot lady?
They showed favoritism to the hot lady, didn't they?
Okay.
I live like a king, I hope this quarantine never ends.
They actually bring you food?
Of course.
Literally anything I want, all you gotta do is ask nicely.
Oh, bro, she's been having sex with the warden, hasn't she been?
Hasn't she been, like, bent over and open wide nicely?
Ashley.
Fuck you, get out of here, get out of here, get out, both of you.
I'm going in your bathroom.
Hey, did I give you permission to go there?
I went in your kitchen.
Girl, don't you at least do your fucking dishes.
Can I steal some of her food?
Someone gave up assembling their furniture.
Why don't you ask the warden to assemble your furniture?
Can we put the nail gun in her head?
Okay.
Neat girlfriend of my dreams.
No, I'm your neat girlfriend of your dreams.
Well, that was something.
How come we got such different treatments?
Why don't I get food?
I guess you're just not pretty enough.
You think she's pretty?
Wasn't she?
No, shut up about objectively.
Yeah, his stock is plummeting.
I'm selling Andrew coin right now.
Is it okay to leave her there after she saw us though?
Probably not, but you go in there swinging your...
You go in there swinging your cleaver and she'll definitely scream.
Blonds are just hotter?
I can't tell if you're trying to give me a compliment or not.
You can admire something without wanting it?
No, you can't!
You cannot admire something without wanting it.
Don't be admiring...
Don't be admiring shit in front of me.
I think our best bet is to finish the ritual
and use it to get rid of the second warden.
Well, if we can get this woman up to the cultist room,
we've got us assault to offer.
How on earth are we going to convince her lazy ass
to even leave her room?
Beats me, let's just finish setting up the ritual for now.
Alright.
Do you really think I'm not pretty enough?
Oh, come on!
So ugly am I?
So ugly that I shouldn't even be fed?
Or maybe they think...
Or maybe they didn't think it'd be fun to screw you
while I'm loitering around the house.
Oh yeah, okay, fair point.
You're already my type, Imi?
Good.
I am admiring nothing.
I only have eyes for you.
That's how it should be!
No, don't admire any stupid missiles.
Stupid missiles.
Missiles don't have holes in them.
Okay, anyways.
I wouldn't let them anyways.
YEEEHHH!
Thank you!
You better not let them.
Unknown the door is too big.
Okay.
Is anyone else home?
Not soft holes at least.
Yeah.
You want to fuck a missile?
Go ahead, be my guest.
Oh, another floor.
Oh wait, this is our floor.
Wait, what did we want to do?
We wanted to finish setting up the ritual, right?
How do we do that?
A walkie-talkie.
Useless.
I don't know, at least we'll hear if the others
weren't trying to contact this one.
Which then indicates time is running out for us.
Only admire Amy, yeah.
No, don't admire any other girls.
And don't want any other girls either.
Big deal.
At that point, we're screwed anyway.
Hey, what if we call the warden over with this
and have the demon eat his soul?
That's not a bad idea, actually.
Two birds with one stone!
Though he'll come in guns blazing.
Ah, right.
Let me think.
Right.
While you're at it, I'll read the ritual for us.
What do I need to do?
I don't remember.
Check the guidebook.
I keep leaning over on my chair to try to fart,
but it's not coming out.
I'm getting stream,
I'm getting stream shy or something.
Jake isn't a girl.
Stay out of trouble.
I'm not falling for you.
You're a missile now in me
since four-
Well-
Well...
Well you're-
I'm having an in--
is trying to read that.
Check the guidebook.
What guidebook?
the runes feed it out guidebook guidebook I know the runes feed it out
where's the guidebook
left corner oh what's needed to finish this ritual
I did it I did it did you hear that I fucking did it I I didn't fart in the
mic I hope you heard it please tell me you heard that please
you heard that right you didn't hear huh you gotta be shitting me you did some of
you didn't hear it it sounded like boom please my volume was too low okay if you
turn it up maybe you can hear it can you do it again I can't control my farts I
can't control my farts no I can't do it again I heard something like a cheer
movie I leaned over like I leaned over on my chair and then forwarded because I
can't fart while I'm sitting on my butt obviously I can't control it please okay
trash some runes on the floor with blood I'm not sure what runes though I'll
just reach out with the guy already had they seem to work okay take his blood
get his blood it dip your digits in one of the ward rooms are you gay why are
you acting so gay call me a fm 92 stinger with a way on laser focused on
the hot thing in front of me thank you for the next time do it into the mic I'll
try I'll try it's just that when I actually stood up like last time I when
I felt a fart coming and I actually stood up to fart it went away so I didn't
want to lose the opportunity you know if it was coming now it's coming now
him he's a missile oh okay I'm not missile-pilled I'm sorry okay now draw
the runes oh shit I have an idea oh let's have a lady from downstairs lure
the warden up here with the walkie-talkie how are we gonna make her do
that you know how no I don't huh all right then let's go convince her I was
at something else was was there something else that still need to be set up
secondary I am not setting up a secondary for Mike just for you to listen to my
farts do we give you a kiss now okay why are you acting so gay here's your
reward for farting on stream thank you I'm looking here you can have a kiss now
do a condenser mic for whatever farts leave it at your level nah it's gonna
cause so much noise extra noise for nothing
choo-choo anyone who's wearing headphones might be able to hear it
better but there's your kisses just slaying the candles and turning on the
audio but I think it's best to do that one once the warden is on the way yeah
wouldn't want to keep the demon waiting um how do we call her wait what's their
plan yeah a fart and a kiss a blessed day truly what's their plan
I don't have headphones but I've heard it through my living room speakers okay so
somebody okay it was audible you two again sorry sorry there's one last thing
we forgot to ask you what I thought I made myself clear what do you want hey
get off me oh my god what's going to happen now is that you'll cool into this
walkie-talkie huh tell them that you and his friend are looking for a good time
up in room 405 I don't understand you only need to understand will slit your
throat if you don't play nice no please I'll do anything I'll tell him anything
meet time this chat is down bad horrendous well you're in this chat too so
you count too we'll see you press the walkie-talkie hello huh who's there hi
Dave it's me where's Malcolm um Malcolm's here with me in room 405 did you
care for a quick visit a quick visit huh I mean if you want to have a good time
that is um well well I'll be I'm always up for a good time if you know what I
mean was there in 405 I guess that weirdo really croaked um nothing I'll be
right there sweet cheeks you cut the conversation there all right good let's
go I like go over now and what do you think she'll do I won't do anything I
promise go finish it I'll keep her quiet until it's done
I don't want him to stay alone in this room with her my brother in Christ this
is a little too replay I don't know what you're talking about this is a
completely wholesome clean family-friendly stream what get going
dumbass fine they like catch you hurry back up to finish the ritual do you not
trust Andy with this hussy I don't well I just don't trust the hussy you know
hmm it's now the time for jealousy it's always time for jealousy okay I'm ready
for now am I supposed to hide music music oh yes so now what am what am I
supposed to oh who are you I can't see you're asking my name human huh what do
you offer oh yikes did I mess up I don't want to pay for its name hmm I'm
here kind of dark huh I'm not I'm not doing it with this kind of music on
let's if she's not jealous I don't want her real real shocked to the warden
reaches for his gun ah him I offer him what so well how is it human with tar
colored soul I give you this target colored soul unidentifiable small
object I want to make a penis joke there but I won't hold it for an occasional
clairvoyant dream to gouge the Troubles ahead thank you
yeah the entity has left why do the dead bodies look like that oh they're
upside down that's why you're still alive unlike either of the wardens man
that all happened way too fast in the end I didn't get its name nor to ask for
a favor it's the clairvoyant object two inches I wasn't gonna make a joke about
my penis come on it was about yours I spilled water on the mic yes my 7 inch
Excalibur my 7 inch wand my 7 inch Gucci destroyer my my pen it's um
and it definitely just gave me whatever trash was lying around as demon
pockets but no matter the warden is dead and if I have even one clairvoyant
dream that'd be cool as hell
pinkie-pumper so mean you decide not to linger on the fact your soul is
fairly a viscous pitch black mess yes you already knew that I'm all right let
me go get let me go get Andy cuz like check the oh fuck sorry
I'm just shooting just kidding I'll probably shoot the lady though oh my god
please do
why are all the girls in this video game annoying other than Laylee
um okay um in here what did you do she tried to shoot me with a nail gun how
on earth I thought you were holding her in place well I let go why did you let
go you're taking a while I figured she wouldn't start anything as long as I
had my cleaver lesson learned how interesting that you'd want to take
your chances with that for no reason what are you getting at you were trying
to fuck her weren't you that's why you let her go and then she tried to shoot
you with her nail gun you did say she was pretty I didn't try anything with her
yeah okay yeah yeah and here I was wondering why you insisted on staying
behind hi mercy yeah what an asshole I should shoot him with my gun teach him
a lesson Andrew shoots his load while I risk getting shot by the warden are you
unaware that the lady is left dead right now I guess she said no secure you
actually almost got shot too that's your own fault for letting her go I can't
believe what a dumbass you are when it comes to women for the last time I
wasn't trying to get with her and even if I had which I didn't so what she's dead
now okay that makes it fine good to know why wouldn't we trust Annie well he
wanted to stay behind with the girl so like that's us why do you want to stay
behind with her yeah you have one fucking job
fucking every time every time indeed every time some fucking floozie comes
around yeah I'm not so a bit what's it what's it to you it's always the same
with you you get to dip your dick in some bitch and the rest of the world
disappears not true yeah it is cock-brained now is definitely not the
time for this I just need you to get your priorities straight my priority right
now is getting out of here your priority should be me blow it out your ass I'm
not having this argument here of all places I know shut up you don't tell
I didn't screw the neighbor lady and on that note will you back the fuck off of
my love life Ashley what's not supposed to mean oh I got spit on my freaking
cough drop because I need to get into this argument I'm invested now
oh I don't know it's not like my girlfriend dumped me after you harassed
the hell out of her or something what she told you what a tattletale you're
better off without some loose-lipped or I love a good argument so it really was
you yeah all I did was weed out a quitter for you you're welcome and I
wouldn't harass anyone if you'd stop ignoring me when I need you you always
need something well I'm sorry I'm a little bit fucking needy is that a
problem for you you always have some bullshit crisis the moment I'm supposed
to meet up with someone but you bloody love it here when I can't but you bloody
love it here where I can't as much as take a piss without you knowing fuck yeah
I do we be together huh and I bet you'd love it if I killed myself then where'd
that come from fuck what a prime example of your just you you would you would I
know it already I'm right where you want me huh I'll do it then I can just for
you you know I have just the thing for that back at your beck and call just
like it was back when what no screw you Andrew don't act like I'm the bad guy
here I love this argument so much yeah you won't let me watch you pee do you
even love me if you won't let me watch you pee I'm never once made you do
anything but it's always I don't want to I don't want to with you well answer me
this what do you want then well see if you'd have listened to a word I said you
know I why don't you want to speak that why don't you want to spend time with me
anymore I've done nothing but spend time with you gay why are you acting so gay
thank you anonymous for the 69 boundaries goddamn no why are you trying to put
boundaries with me do you hate me yes let me
I mean I've done nothing but spend time with you for the past three months well
it wasn't quality time so then why aren't we friends anymore of course we are
just forget this can we just go no we can't just go apologize to me just go
no answer me what were you about to say stay then I'm going oh no you don't
bro grab the knife grab the knife point the gun at him point the gun at him what's
so bad about me I've been looking out for you isn't that what some likes do
just don't go I'll hold it for you when you go don't worry I won't go
helicopter just stop what talk to me it's not my fault I didn't lock us in
I didn't kill the cultist I didn't even kill the warden which one neither you did
and the demon I'm all innocent I have not harmed a single soul of course not
you make me do it for you I didn't make you do shit Andrew you chopped the bastard
up all by yourself oh my god I love her gaslighting and you choose to do
everything you've done here and guess what Andy don't I love his depressed
luck okay hold on I'm gonna go get more water again I'll be right back two
minutes not even two minutes
okay I'm back this time I did actually go to the bathroom and I didn't wash my
hands cuz you weren't there to wash them for me I'm sorry was that actually
over two minutes I'm sorry if it was I didn't wash my hands no you weren't there
for me to wash them so I didn't wash my hands okay
if you want to anyway it's back to the game don't you chose to lock blank in
that crate where should I actually scream I kind of want to wear the fucking
cunt choked cry yourself to sleep to that Andy my poor Andy okay so that just
came out of your mouth what it's true you chose to do that and you chose me you
chose me me you backpedaling fuck of a brother you chose me you did you did I
guess we're not leaving here together you can't do it you won't you can't
cuz I'm the only one you can talk to and you can't sleep at night and you
can't take it I'm the only one who can give fuck I can't make it sexy when I'm
sick like this fuck I'm the only one who can make it go away fancy that when
you're the reason I can't sleep in the first place sorry yeah I'm the reason you
can't sleep I've been keeping you up at night bouncing on that anyways I would
like to go now with Andy I'm ready to go now yes yes yes kill me
right now please of course not I want to leave this appointment before we get
caught with you can we go oh wait I can't open a new cough drop I already had
when I spat it out I like to go too but the thing is you're pissing me off so
much right now we go now and you'll just throw another fit later that's the
point yes I'm your sister that's that's the reason I'm here yeah yeah I
probably will make such a scene too yeah so I don't know if I can risk it maybe
I'll just end you here and be done with though if you can come up with a
compelling reason not to I won't well I already said there are sleeping pills
for that yeah okay I got nothing but I'd like to go with you very much though if
you plan on ditching me anyways and fuck you if it's not going to be just the
two of us and forget it oh you mean chill you're trying to get your toes
sucked I don't give a shit about blank I'm glad she choked I know you are no one
knows it was us so what doesn't matter as long as it's just us are you saying
you'll behave yes yes I will yes I will I will I will I'll behave if you behave
isn't that how it goes who knows with you those though I'm assuming we're
getting out of here in the first place her bruise neck is so hot it's not
bruised anymore they didn't put it on the splash art fuck oh my god the screaming
really took it out of me bros the screaming really took it out of me
that's right our quest continues what did we name this episode again Andy and
okay but I'm not gonna be Andy anymore huh he's so spineless I hate Laili like
he wouldn't believe huh she better stay and die here here with Andy so you and
I can leave what does he mean by that damn he left marks are you coughing cuz
big bro boost your neck too I'm coughing cuz I'm sick fine whatever that means in
practice I like you but you're so exhausting I know I'm invigorating let's
leave and never revisit this conversation yes I've got the keys to the second floor
and there's also the wardens gun yeah I'm sick guys sick in the head I'm
surprised you didn't shoot me yet maybe later let's get out of here Andrew God
please tell me there's more scenes like that I need more of that that was so
amazing god oh my god I wish I wish it wasn't my phone buzzing right now yeah
what if they kissed a little that would have been better okay um second floor new
floor and lock let's read it oh we can't read it hello check the body if you
want a small thought oh should I check the body it means gonna be wild on
Twitter I actually wasn't going to until you told me until you said that not told
me but until you said that maybe I will um I'm confused about these floors now my
happiness isn't measurable what about the body you said check the body for
surprise you're gonna love episode two I'm already loving it I need check
there's nothing there snooping around a lady's bathroom were you I had to wash
your blood off of me all right excuse accepted thanks
bless you guys are so cute um where can I get golf in me soon soon literally Friday
I want to design it I don't know if I my schedule for next week is a little fucked
up we'll see take the nail gun what are you doing you dumbass um but yeah we're
not gonna play through this whole thing today but I want to play through like a
good chunk of it because I really am enjoying it I'm enjoying it sue me sue me
I like the incest couple okay where do I go now
when I go
window what do you mean oh
wow thanks okay geez look an open window great jump only if you jump
with me time to me not Andrew I mean it is only the second floor you really
don't want to take your chances with that damn it isn't there like a rope or
something we can use to climb down use the the carpet use the carpet use the
carpet I'm not sure how we're going to secure it though you hold it while I
descend oh yeah and I'll just jump into your arms once you're down would that
actually work maybe if you catch me instead hell no it won't we've got to
set up something to hold the carpet in place we'll be climbed down thank you
for telling me where could go let's leave it by the window for now got
carpeted okay now what it would have been romantic if they jumped but it's
they're already bought they've already gone through so much you can't you can't
jump now nail gun I would catch you in Princess Curie you thank you this
fuck-ass Andy is too weak to catch me that's not where the nail gun is this is
where the nail gun is why did they let me pick up the nail gun from before I
wanted to pick it up just let me pick it up now
okay now nail it nail it nail it it doesn't look safe this whole thing has
been saved I'm going for it if nothing else maybe the carpet slows my descent
down I mean I guess all right you first then damn right I go first damn right
nerd I am a lady you climb down very un-lady like we made it I like how he
follows me what happens now there is no drapes all right no I do have drapes
there is no carpet
okay anyways
and find the buffet restaurant and then we'll steal someone's identity or
or something to continue our lives easy peasy huh and then as long as we never
come in contact with law enforcement we'll live a quiet life and die you've
got it all figured out good god I have no idea what we're gonna do Ashley I did
not win yet no remember that for a minute hey why are you disappointed you
carpet munchers okay let's get let's go to a real touristy location maybe some
traveler will drop their ID then we'll rent a place using that I'm sure we'll
find some grunt work somewhere too I even I don't think that's going to shut
your mouth shut your mouth it'll work out lest we'll live under a bridge or
something like trolls will eat those who pay the toll to cross oh who won't pay
the toll to cross haha how can you laugh it's anything but funny how can you do
anything else but laugh everything has gone to crap haha keep it together I am
let's start by catching a bus okay that was your nickname in high school I'm
happy to be out of there too and otherwise I'm a hair away from a panic
attack thanks for asking I didn't get to tell you before but the friend I called
while you were downstairs gave me a gift do I even want to know supposedly I
should be seeing visions of the future in my sleep now who knows well I hope you
do would be handy when things come to avoiding certain things I mean you're
not a lady you're there you're the lady damn right I'm the lady yep so you can
relax a bit I'll hold I'll keep my sleeping eyes open but that also means
you can't leave now you're stuck with me nothing new under the sun stop being
so depressed about being stuck with me you should be happy you're stuck huh are
you oh yeah completely stuck
I need to get my blushing email now oh my god
you can't have us and drive the hell out of there end of episode one okay that's
safe game no fuck you I do want to save the game do you guys want to go through a
little bit of episode two what do you want is this me and you and me it is we
can go through a little bit of episode two second episode is much longer okay I
definitely want to finish the game for sure how stay as long as you do does it
bear shit in the woods okay okay we'll go ever so to avoid episode two a little
bit not not the whole thing but a little bit a little bit because like I'm
liking it too much to stop this is like a dating simulator for me you're
finishing up what's left of your lunch the consequences of your actions have
yet to catch up with you which is nice there's nothing interesting in this
paper huh I'm not done reading it's been a week the odds that there is
something now are nonexistent just let me check I'm bored how much longer can we
stay here anyways we're almost out of money
technically I have money I just can't use it without giving away where I am to
the pink you have money what there's something you'll like in episode two is
it sex cuz that's the only thing I want right now what's invaders in me are you
able to save midway that's a great question am I wait really wait really
there is
how do we find it wait how do I actually save wait what button do I press to
save just gonna show you my entire fucking computer I save I don't know
invaders in amazing Nickelodeon show back in the day
I have to be walking around oh okay okay okay okay I just want to know how to
save for the future but thank you I don't get why they want to check my ID for
every fucking thing I got damn I just wanted to stay at a hotel why do I need
to know why do they need to know who I am I'm paying up from dark aren't I so
it's not like I bail out on them whoo-hoo this motel is just fine too
right the motel he totally seemed like an invaders him kind of girl maybe I do
know what invaders him is hold on and move that over invaders him I've seen this
show before I'm okay here's the thing I never watch Nickelodeon so I don't know
a lot of Nickelodeon shows what's in history I'm not showing you what's in
history
it's really nice where I heard gunshots last night or was that just you haven't
shot anything yet what I think I left my gun back in the room I really wish
you'd be less nonchalant about everything all the time I'm moderately
terrified of your searches wait there's literally nothing what do you mean you
didn't even see my search history
you mean I'm literally literally checking my search history yeah there's
nothing there so in this chapter there's a ton of stuff to interact with show it
no okay I really wish you'd be less nonchalant about everything all the time
hey now we can't both be constantly shitting ourselves over every little
thing true let's just go back to the motel before someone breaks in and steals
a damn thing why would someone break in eat food wait this is actually funny
this reminds me of something when I was in high school me and my friend made a
trash a potted plant subsists among cigarette but when I was in high school
me and my friend for 11th grade final we decided to draw a comic together and
this isn't even a funny story it's just reminds me of something and in the
comic we had to draw some advertisements and our advertisements were
basically just the words like that eat food drink Pepsi friend guys it's a girl
it was a girl she was one of my besties in high school I miss her she's not that
she's not that she's not that she's not that is she single? she's a lesbian
just kidding get out the road stupid
that clearly doesn't answer the question it doesn't matter also why are you
asking if my friend is single don't worry about my friend an ad for a coffee
shop it's difficult to imagine the aroma of warm cup of coffee with trash running
next to you can we be lesbians? shut up everybody she's single shut up do you hate me is that
why you're asking are you tired of me already are you tired of living in
where is the ad? ask your doctor if you think she's ready for you
soft drink ad there are three new and exciting flavors living at a time only
okay cool oh caramelized apple cinnamon I want to try that no we only love any
that's right that's right thank you
say it again three more times
that yeah yeah yeah emi is the best little sister in the world and she's the only girl I
need in my life and I love her a lot just like that just like that yeah
I only love emi thank you
we can't afford any nonsense right now oh come on it's just a couple of bucks
you can have that or you can have dinner it's up to you what they said no you have to say it
in full you have to say it in full you can't just bitch out like that there we go that's
what I like to see there we go
good job good boy good job
oh this sucks it's limited time too
I love emi's feet no don't you told me it's my own choice whether I want dinner or soda
well I lied fuck your soda fuck you up yours Andrew what do I even put up with you for
ask myself that every day anyway we're not wasting money on this and that's why
you can't control me let me let me drink my soda what the fuck man
no it's not too crazy
Andrew you poor bitch
oh there was a poster last arrow you missed do I need to see it how much longer do you
think you'll be playing I have no fucking clue my favorite soda is a diet pepsi or diet coke
can we get a good girl too okay good girl you're all my good good boys and girls there
why is there two beds wait actually I just noticed there's two beds but both of the
pillows are on the top bed so they have been sleeping together the closet is empty except for
my gun though it's not really yours anyways but whatever the warden's gun now
it makes you warm do you hear that oh it'll shake I should say more I should say more good boy
okay this is so cute there's no pillow
leave it to Angie to insist on getting a room with two separate beds
only to then have a panic attack every other night I knew he was a little bitch boy okay
wow this motel is actually pretty good they have a freaking washing machine what the hell
only Amy is allowed to be good girl no you can be my good boys and girls too
there's an article about a chemical leak in some city you've never been to
article details instructions for people in the area to stay home and to seal their windows
he can't sleep without Ashley that's so cute that's so cute I love that
going for the the tv get your fat out of the way
ass I think you mean my awesome fat tits you cocksucker move you cow whatever
thank you for telling me to do that keep doing it I'd rather be a bad boy no
no if you want to be a bad boy go with sheebie
uh oh more stuff to pick up hoarding newspaper ever since you arrived
hmm there's nothing worthwhile the paper isn't even comfortable to wipe your ass with
he's been that fucking cocksucker he's been buying newspaper but he won't let me buy a soda
why am I the why am I always the one cleaning isn't he older shouldn't he be the one to clean
that's not fair
aren't you tired of drinking the same old water every day yeah it's so wet have you tried
toxa soda it's water but where is now in three new flavors awful gross and nasty try them today
toxa soda tastes just like life I don't know why I'm drinking this
what do I do now anxiety King Andy he's just like me
ha ha talk to Andy he's just gonna yell at me for being in front of the all done you're welcome
great thanks thank me oh my god if I was actually lay late I would be made I would be the abusive
one holy shit well she's already abusive but I'd be fucking I'd be winding up my fist if you
didn't thank me for doing the laundry I really am such a sweetheart you're so damn lucky to have me
yeah yeah
bro this dude would be in a body bag next to the fucking neighbor I swear I cook and I clean
and I'm a feast on the eyes meanwhile what do you do watch TV all day like a slob
I just realized I turned my freaking mic game all the way up I'm sorry if that was
I'm sorry if that changed anything
knock it off
you're not going to be in the news Andy
oh come on I thought they were gonna have some sort of cutscene
I should have known oh what are you even wait I don't get it what happened
make it higher turn my mic game up why
it's good okay um
oh what are you going to do about it oh she's calling him Andy again
so I can hear you in my soul
oh
gonna choke me out again are you are you
do you want me to yes yes yes yes
oh come on I'm kidding it's all in good fun
I thought we were fine we are I'm just messing around it's just a nickname get over yourself
it's the one thing I asked of you
and it's symbolic dumbass you and your romanticism shove it up your ass I don't know what I was expecting
listen I'm behaving what more do you want I'm being so good to you are you because I'm getting
the the opposite impression here yeah yeah you think I'm so awful huh
oh hold on
barking is cringe these later she's a bark I never said barking was cringe did I
I've been barking
you want to see what it's like when I actually misbehave it could be so much worse
should I show you just how should I show you just how awful I really am
ah go for it that you're going to find me a lot less accommodating than Andy
and now some less important news one of the quarantine departments has had a bit of a situation
I wish she would grab me like that I'll grab you like that
that
nothing major just a fire that burned the whole place down everybody died yes
everybody a representative of the water company is here with us today is there anything you'd like
to add yes my deepest condolences to the family members of the deceased this apartment was most
definitely not a wholly mismanaged mess better burned to the ground so it's good that they escaped
are you even tall enough to grab any just just bend over
I am tall enough to grab you like that you just gotta bend over for me
therefore it is so sad that this happened to ease that sadness we recommend you try our talks
we just rolled out three new and exciting flavors excuse me sir something seems to
be going wrong with your microphone I'm sure you mean to say drink our trusty bubbly pop what
happened which happens to be our sponsor and it doesn't even make your organs bleed out of your
ass unlike some alternatives anyway um that was all for now tune in again later for a more wholesome
news to cheer up your day if you insist I do insist that was our apartment wasn't it was being
the correct tense indeed did I leave the oven on I said everybody died oh that's great isn't it
they must think we died too and all the evidence of our escape escapades let's say has been incinerated
I wonder about that
I told you it'll all work out that still leaves us homeless and just about penniless
whatever things are clearly clearly gonna sort themselves out I'm gonna get some sleep good night
the water company that owns the current in-world coca-cola product talks talks to soda is there
some sort of conspiracy theory that I'm not I'm not that's not clicking for me
I don't know who this bend over person is
I'm gonna stay up a bit longer maybe the late night news will have more information on the fire
suit yourself I don't know in a minute oh okay okay well I guess I'm gonna sleep
as usual you fall asleep without a care in the world
oh shit oh this is the dream someone has entered the room
oh
oh my god oh my god are you alive did you die wake up we gotta go
huh get up I had a vision we're about to get killed we gotta go now
go go go go go go go escape get in the car get in the car where do we go where do we go
tell me where to go rip
we got murder eat it what where do I go
um go left okay
so want to stay here and see if the killer actually shows up
and what did I do to deserve to get murdered for in my sleep anyways
might be a risky a bit risky staying here you don't want that you don't know which direction they came from
right assuming anyone shows up anyway they will I'm sure
have you actually never played this before no I haven't of course not
Andrew lights up his fourth cigarette oh cringe Andrew come on that's not hot come on
way to pull money bro this dude's such an asshole he buys newspapers and cigarettes but I can't buy
some fucking soda
what the hell yeah ill smoker cringe some people think I smoke weed too guys I don't smoke weed
I would never put my rats life in danger like that by smoking weed next to them
it's probably cold because that crap misses with your blood circulation okay mom
makes you impotent too by the way uh that's okay we don't want any babies
it didn't sound like I'd be it didn't sound like I'd be meeting any girls anytime soon anyway
but stopping you I love it when he looks like that
consider hot smoker girl smoking is not hot except in this situation when it is
all right I said enough quiet you I thought we were hiding
that wasn't the guy who you're expecting to come slit your throat he sure looked familiar
didn't we eat that guy don't say that out loud
him calling Ashley mom is a single worse insult he could say why what happened to
their mom what did the mom do
you'll see okay sorry didn't we chop that guy up and store him in a freezer
Ashley come on he seriously though I guess there's more where he came from
or do you suppose he was off to a sex and drugs party with demons duh why are you asking me
whatever should we follow him but I'm trying to see if my vision comes true or not
it's not like we both have to be here really don't want to stand here alone in the middle of the night
but you're also curious
I had to yawn you're also curious about
what the cultist lookalike is up to fine you go but come back soon
no I don't want to be Andrew I don't want to be Andrew
I'm not EP I'm just where did he go this way
talk to Ashley oh
oh good you're not going after all I am just did you see which way he went into the alley right
this alley you can now play as Luigi isn't this the hoodie he was wearing yeah
can I actually make him buy a soda
to the right there's no alley here yo buy your sister a soda
yes yes yes geez okay
now where is he I don't want to switch bodies you know I want to stay as Ashley
get in the alley and go right oh
they'll talk to Ashley oh
hey there I got you something oh is that
I know I disappoint myself too I can't believe they got me with their limited time only BS
aw thank you let me try some right now
you can have the rest it's great it tastes like what nail polish smells like
what a waste of money not at all my curiosity is sated
chemical burn on my tongue aside I really am mighty pleased with this random act of kindness
what do you want in return my virginity yes yes yes
Jesus fucking Christ that's enough of that I mean if you go to a bar and a dude buys your
drink isn't that the logical conclusion which bar is this I should go sometime
actually doesn't that doesn't make sense I doubt the bar I doubt the bar
browsing bitches are very virginal how judgmental of you
oh that's nasty you don't have to finish it just throw it out
you can talk to her again for a bit by the way
never it was a gift
should I keep talking I just wanted to say that if that guy from your vision does show up don't
do anything I'm not actually brain dead believe it or not I don't anyway just hide if you see him
we'll do bye bye
the most skippable
what do you mean oh this way
hold the door please
run suck it run
oh no we got him get him no uh
give the trash
should I go talk to her one more time I can go talk to her again
I know right what kind of lunatic leaves his sister unattended you would never do that to me right
my my someone is feeling chatty tonight he went to the alley next to the shop right see you later
is that it is that it okay you can also look at the notes next to her
cold girl adds stuck to the wall oh my maybe I should leave my number here
absolutely not he's jealous what we need the cash and it would be tax free to boot
say another word and I'll back please back hand me she's learned to take a joke jackass
learned to make a joke dumbass you're so out there that you're so out there that I can't tell
whether you're being serious or not I'm obviously not being serious we don't even own a phone right now
and would you honest to god back hand me just like that well not right there not right here
anyway oh my god okay wow white feeder
oh don't say that it's only towards you on
therapy okay by the way maybe you'll start eating out out of here once your money runs out
so I looked in the trash can there's nothing in there
oh fuck what's the password tell me the password
girl me too
it's on the left oh i'm so stupid there we go
enter
no amount of therapy can fix you that's not true
I don't know why even entertain the idea of it pink anything else
okay at least he's stupid like me oh hi
this game is your therapy it's exposure therapy
sorry was I not supposed to be here this is a private event shoot shoot
is this the sex and demons party I hope not my wife would kill me what the hell are you talking
about there's no such thing
you don't need therapy just somewhere smuggling what are what am I smuggling
no there is no demon sex party oh well just a regular demon summoning then
I mean that's what I was told but listen who the hell invited you you're not even dressed properly
right sorry
another silent fart
right sorry I didn't know there was a dress code I don't know who told you about today
but you can go kick rocks all right I'll go no harm done why would you go
six eyes is getting popular we should be glad so I'm guessing our neighbor was part of these
guys little club invested more fiber you really want to hear my audible parts
huh we're pretty far from home though maybe they gathered at multiple locations can these guys
actually summon demons though I mean our neighbors managed it eventually but
you decide you should get inside somehow and find out
how do I get inside
oh my god Rhea hi Rhea welcome welcome Rhea and and her viewers hello
oh it's so nice to see you oh my goodness this is gonna be embarrassing for any of your
viewers that stay how was your stream Rhea here let me make you a mod real quick
I gotta make make our pooky real mod hold on
I just basically make any new vtuber that joins a mod
there you go
okay it was good how was your stream how was your streaming it's been really fun to be honest
I didn't expect to have so much fun but like this game is making me bark and stuff
so I like it who's Rhea it's Rhea Nevermore from Yume Plus
you should you guys should go check her out she's also from a vtuber company
one day Emi will give me a wrench what do you mean what is that supposed to mean
I've been really down bad for this game
you decide that if a wave forward doesn't strike you before you're done with your smoke you'll just
call it quits and then just as you're putting your smoke out there's a key under the cigarette
butt jar oh shit okay go through here then oh this looks like a crack house what are they
making in here are these pancakes full of cake Laura has some paper it's a freaking um
um it's a it's a job what what do they call it
a mod wrench I'm not gonna make you mod don't ask to be mod it's an office party it's an office party
the game could say I'm gonna strangle you it it may be like yes yes do it do it
anyways stop eating my lynch you animals
someone has left a note it reads to whoever ate my casserole I will have your head on a plate
the office life same shit different toilet I've never worked in an office before I don't know
I wouldn't know the drab is set of drapery you have ever laid eyes on the drapery is white
can I not stay as can I stay as not a mod what do you mean not a mod
come here then
don't ask to be mod you have to earn it you have to earn it
the buttons won't work without a swipe tag oh is there one in here
swipe tag swipe tag swipe or no swiping
how do we earn it I don't know by watching and then applying for mod
whenever the dealer puts out a mod application so that's pretty much it
where do I get the swipey swipe here prove yourself by helping me
they're just gonna kick you out again I know
mods remove this guy's mitochondria
no please help me tell me what to do please the shop door to the right but then where do I go
oh wait you mean the actual shop like the store oh wait check the cake stand near the elevator
people aren't begging for mod we're just goofing we're just goofing around don't worry
that fart was not audible either on the cart sit plate yeah sits plates full of cake
and a coffee dispenser what's with the cakes it's a bit late for a work meeting
hide hide hide hide what do I do
did I hide in the right place this is going to take two trips
one of the carts down the elevator with him oh oh I hide in the cart
oh oh oh okay
you can certainly squeeze yourself into the cart now but you'd be in you'd be seen in sleep
what do I do what do I do
I did it I did it without your help oh my god I'm so smart
use the drapery I did it I did it hmm uh oh he shows a piece of cake in his mouth
oh oh dark lord that is good he carts you into the elevator he's so smart fuck yeah
how's this cart so much heavier than the other could it be the weight of my sins no
oh my god okay okay be cool no one has to know it's between me and the towel just act
oh my god this guy's just like me did I miss it shh
guys when are we getting to the freaky scene
I need to get my freak on
sorry did he say something I wasn't reading it's 2 a.m and I'm falling asleep so I'm just
gonna snuggle up next to you oh good night good night
it'll be a while
no
the ritual is all set up now I know you're all excited about the free coffee but first
yo this cult is kind of based
I don't want part two I want it now I want it now
oh
tell me how many more hours
tell me how many more hours until until the until the scene and then I will decide
this is such fun reveal yourself to us lord unknown the cult is keep playing for the lord unknown
10 hours oh maybe two
you guys are all giving me different answers
two to three um
don't get one guy I want something now yeah I don't want to play faster though I want to enjoy the
game okay I'll finish this scene and then we will go raid oh the fuck are we gonna raid um
uh Azura yeah but it's become increasingly clear nothing is going to show up wow look at this
amateur hour my ashley summoned something my ashley my ashley summoned something on her first
try though that's probably not a good thing is it
I feel lord unknown is with us today but only in spirit
I brought the cards down but someone stole one of the cakes it was you
oh can we have some now yes please enjoy yourselves
where are your robes sorry the thing is spilled the thing is spilled some coffee the thing is I
spilled some coffee on them huh idiot I wish I had what they have me till what you do have what
they have with me you don't need to wish you do have it
what wait what did he say that was the thing
should be fine to take two pieces right look how many there are
you're not as crazy though do you want me to be
oh my first audio is pretty crazy have you asked me
slime girl sounds tame but when I if I'm the one writing it um I have an inability to make it tame
I can I can show you the script if you want here let me let me spoil some of the slime
girl's script for you and then you know what's coming oh wait that's not the right account
spoilers just because you're here with me ignore that ignore me casually going on my personal
account I don't like to write scripts on the company account um
um
here here here let me let me let me voice some of the slime girl's script for you
god I can't laugh naturally
um
caught you where do you think you're going now gonna leave me like everyone else
aw you're shivering like a leaf poor thing don't worry I'll calm you right down just relax
let me take care of you okay there that's all I'm gonna say um
you're welcome you got it like two weeks earlier
someone is underdressed
this way of voice acting is so nostalgic what do you mean nostalgic to what
um do I just keep talking to people those cheap asses offer milk for the coffee instead of cream
also the beer they still taste like piss not that I've ever drank
bro is this a pinpower right now we'll say something
where'd you where'd you hear about this gathering in the first place the occult magazine I'm
subscribed to had an ad I figured it was going to be lame but
but
the misline was that Andrew misses Ashley by the way uh-huh
is it safe work yeah yeah yeah this one's safer work it's gonna be on youtube
I figured it was going to be lame but I thought I'd come check it out since I don't live too far away
what about you same anyways I gotta go it was nice talking to you see you next time
the next time I thought she didn't like it here
is this dude singing I'm on stage it's like I'm famous
I like to re I like to see you redo some of your early audios in like a year and see how you grow as a
voice actor
I don't know I feel like um my earlier audios weren't really interesting because they were all
they were all pre-made scripts you know so um
if you want to hear a better version of those ones just go find the same script
and listen to it from someone else not from me
oh sorry she has begun singing people are staring time to get out of here oh okay
I have to go to bed okay good night how do I open this how do I leave did I not finish
taste the piss beer taste the piss beer
bottom left
oh oh oh shit
I gotta fart again
I did it
okay
okay okay
Just don't let this happen again. Have a good night. Okay. Okay. I'm gonna save here
Save
File one
Did I do it?
You're calling me a good girl for partying.
Sounded a little wet. Shut up. It was not wet. I think I saved, right?
Am I doing this right? Okay. Yeah, I
Did not sure I would be I would be so honest with you if I sharded
Okay, but
Okay
Let me quit the game too. That was really fun. I
Didn't expect to have as much fun reading that the scenes. Oh my god, some of those scenes were
Oh
Yeah, you guys should you guys should keep an eye on Twitter after this not for any specific reason
Let me add a redirect to
Zero, okay
Coffin like really hard now
You're nearly halfway through really it's only three hours into the game though
Well, thank you for coming. It was really fun
Um, I I'm not sure it went gay. Why are you acting so gay?
I love you. I mean get some rest and hope you feel better soon
Thank you. I love you too. Thank you
Yeah, thank you for coming to the stream I'm gonna go shower and then
Yeah
Okay, um, um, I will see you again tomorrow. I didn't always forget my schedule. What are we even doing tomorrow?
What are we doing
We're making poppin cooking. It's a hand cam. I'll make sure to to improve my um, yeah
Camera quality for tomorrow because I know our hand cam yesterday was like really shit quality
I will I'll make sure it's better tomorrow. Thank you for coming. I love you and I loved the stream
Um, oh sorry poppin cooking. It's like DIY candy. Basically. We're making our own candy tomorrow. Yeah
Have a good night. Have fun. I add Anna zero's channel. Um, yeah
Bye. Bye for now
Oh
You